Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Paneme siis Screenshare I
Õpetaja: Okei, ma mõtlesin ee. Paar asja mida teha. Ee, esimene asi, mis ma teeksin, on See, et ma teen Comiti ja ma pusin selle pilve ära Ja siis mängin teiega need sammud läbi, et kui te tahate kiirelt järgi tulla Või tahate lihtsalt Järgi tulla? Täpselt sinna kohta, kus mina olen. Soovite seda teha, Võiks ühe korra kõik läbi harjutada selle nii või Naa,
Õpetaja: ee, Screenshot on. Ee, nii. See eeldab seda, et rain tee üks kommit.
Õpetaja: No teeme Comiti.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, lisasin.
Õpetaja: Ee, lisasin asju Ee Teeme Skip It Simple. Vajutan siit alt nuppu. Ee, siis ta käivitab kaks asja nagu Jadana, et ta teeb Commit I ära nende failide osas, mis on siin Selected.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: vahel võib öelda ka siin, et kuule Viskab mingi eraldi väikse akna lahti. Vaata, ütleb, et Aa, et Kui sul on, sul on halva halb kood või mida iganes, oled sa ikka kindel? Mida iganes, siis paned anyway.
Õpetaja: Aga, noh, push I, jaoks Ta küsib. Ta Comiti Nüüd tegi ära. Aga ta push E ei tee jälle punane piir. Kas ma ikka tõesti tahan, Push, Ida Seda või mitte. Vaata, ta annab mulle võimaluse.
Õpetaja: Mina teen pluss
Õpetaja: need sammud. Ee, proovi. Proovige nüüd meelde jätta. Vaata ka, et, ee, mis Siis teha ma nüüd korra mängin, et ma olen nagu teie teie arvutis. Et ma teen siin lihtsalt mõned reavahetused.
Õpetaja: Teil on hetkel ee Arvatavasti ju kommitimata töö. Mingisugused muudatused, Et kui te tulete selle tööriista, peale,
Õpetaja: siis teil peaks olema mingid failid, mis on lahtised, teil On Nüüd kaks varianti. Te olete seal. Näiteks Ee Jaroslov V üks. Või mis iganes Harul onju Enda nimelises harus. Teil on kaks varianti. Kas Te commit ite need asjad ära
Õpetaja: ja nad lähevad siit eest ära. Aga nad ei ole lahtised. Muudatused. Või Teine variant on see, et, Noh, kui praegusel hetkel, kui te lihtsalt tahate minule järgi tulla, et te võite lihtsalt, mis tähendab seda, et kõik need faili muudatused, mis teil on lahti, siis te lihtsalt viskate nad põhimõtteliselt prügikasti minema ära.
Õpetaja: Miks see on vajalik, on see, et kui te tulete, võtate uue Haru. Ee minu Niiöelda sellest. Ee, harust. Võtate uue haru. Siis seal on täpselt need samad failid, mis on teil hetkel lihtsalt kommittimata kujul lahti
Õpetaja: ja siis on niimoodi, et ega tema, ee, ei tea, mida teha nende failidega
Õpetaja: et selles. Mõttes tal tekib. Tal võib tekkida konflikt, Ta võib proovida neid üle tuua ja nii edasi. Aga tal võib tekkida raskusi, Kuna just mina olen nendes failides ka muudatusi teinud, ehk Siis need lahtised muudatused. Tegelikult, iga kord, kui te hakkate mistahes haruvahetust tegema,
Õpetaja: peab vaatama seda. Aga kas mul on mingi lahtistööd sellepärast, et, Ee, see kui sa see hetk. Kui te vajutate,
Õpetaja: siis täpselt sinna harusse. Need lähevad näiteks praegult. Ma nagu näitan korra, Ma saan vahetada Haru, Mul on need ekstra read siin Rida kümme. Üksteist kaksteist, kolmteist, kui. Ma läheksin näiteks. Praegult aa Masteri peale seal Muidugi nii. Palju, Muid muudatusi ka. Ma isegi ei tea. Ma vaatan, mis juhtub.
Õpetaja: Üritan minna Masteri peale, aga mul tegelikult on ju mingid õhus rippuavad muudatused.
Õpetaja: Need ei kuulu. Need ei kuulu siia Selle õpetaja harusse hetkel veel. Neid pole miititud sinna Ära
Õpetaja: Need on lihtsad muudatused. Midagi ei ole, Et see ei saa olla, niimoodi, Et Kit otsustab minu eest, et Davai. Mine Masteri peale ja näed nüüd ruttu automaatselt ee vaikimisi sinna Õpetaja Harusse ära. Ta ei tee nii.
Õpetaja: Ta üritab neid kaasa võtta, siis. Ja siis kas tal õnnestub see või mitte? Siis ta võib midagi ette visata, kui ma panen need minema Asteri peale.
Õpetaja: Vaata, hetkel ta isegi ütleb. Vaata problem. Your Local Changes viitab sellele samale failile on The Following Files on see, et nagu pane kuhugi riiulile, kus need muudatusi on alati võimalik kätte saada. On ju
Õpetaja: checkout on unself Them after that. Vaata, on, ju, et. Noh, põhimõtteliselt on ka variant niimoodi, et smart checkout. Mis on uus asi see on kandja nagu See, et okei ikkagi. Proovi minna sinna Masterharusse ja proovi võtta kaasa ka need muudatused. Ja kui tal õnnestub, siis see õnnestub force Checkout, on üldse see, et ta ütleb et kuule, need muudatused Tsau Baka
Õpetaja: on ju. Ja siis siis niiöelda ta teeb selle checkout I ära, Aga pigem on ikkagi see õige. Protseduur on selline, et ainult kaks valikut.
Õpetaja: Kas sa kommit Id oma vee ühte näiteks need muudatused ära Ja need on seal alles. Noh, ongi. Näiteks tahad pärast vaadata? Ütleme niimoodi, et midagi läheb katki. Tahad ise kodus hiljem näiteks vaadata. Pusida, et. Oo, mis läks katki? No tee, siis
Õpetaja: kui mitte nad sinna harusse ära võtad. Õpe õpetaja pealt uue haru. Vaata, on ju Ja Lähed edasi, On ju mingi V Kahega uus haru nimi. Haru nime ei saa kaks korda olla. Repositooriumis. Ühte sama nime
Õpetaja: ei saa olla, et Mul on siin kaks harunimega õpetaja. Sest kui minu käsk oleks. See et Kuule, palun Checkout õpetajat, palun võta haruopetaja ja seal oleks Kaks haru, siis. Kuidas Kip peaks teadma? Vaata, Pumba. Haru, Mina mõtlen. Vaata, on ju, et nimed on harude mõttes unikaalsed.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast on ka väga standard, et enamus arendustest pannakse arenduse. Aa arenduse Aa arenduse haru nimeks pannakse taaski number. Sul on ju mingi töölõik,
Õpetaja: Veb kuusteist asju, See süsteem on niikuinii juba kordumatu. Iga uus tiket on uus number.
Õpetaja: On ju, et ei ole niimoodi, et me teeme täna mingit arendust, et oo ja siis kunagi hiljem teeme uue arenduse, mis on mingi vana asjaga seotud. Vaata, et nad kuidagi ei läheks tagasi ja kasutaks Mingit numbrit, mis on varasemalt kasutatud? Ei, tuleb ikka uus.
Õpetaja: Kui on vaja võibolla viidata, et, noh, by the way Varasemalt tegime midagi sarnast vaata, Nagu seal onju, siis see taaskis võib olla lihtsalt teksti kujul olemas. Vaata, et et taaskis on see informatsioon. See on seotud ühe Teise taskiga. Näiteks onju? Või ongi nagu ka mingi tulevikuarendus Ja teeme mitu inimest teevad Mitu asja nad on omavahel seotud Seal taaskis võib olla viited nagu numbritena nagu teistele taaskidele.
Õpetaja: Aga selles mõttes tiket on ikkagi ainult üks ja üks ja ainus. Ja see garanteerib ka Vaata, Kui me kõik meeskonnana koos töötame, ei saa juhtuda seda, kui see standard on Lhv. See oli standard, Niimoodi, et number
Õpetaja: väiksed niisugused ee Automaatsid ja asjad olid peal ka. Vaata, et kui sa näiteks kommitima hakkasid, koodi, et siis sa pidid alustama sõnumit ka alati näiteks v seitse. Ja siis kirjutasid sinna midagi,
Õpetaja: et, ee, on mingisugused. Aa, tavad ja. Ja nagu lahendused, kuidas erinevad ettevõtted nagu oma asju majandavad,
Õpetaja: see jälle sõltub. Vaata ettevõtte kultuurist ja asjadest. Kuidas nemad asju teevad. Aga suht standard on see, et ee, haru nimeks läheb. Näiteks üldse tiketinumber Kas sinna läheb mingi teksti juurde või mitte, Siis sõltuvad jälle kuidas kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Aga enamus ajast, mis teil on, nagu see, Kui te tahate kiirelt järgi tulla. Teil on kama kaks. Vaata, mis te seal katki tegi. Vaata, et seda, teid ei huvita siis kõige lihtsam lahendus on,
Õpetaja: et iga kord, kui te tahate järgi tulla, siis ta esimene asi on see, et siin Changes peab olema tühi ja siin ei saa olla ka unversion. Files
Õpetaja: nagu faili, mis ei ole kitt I lisatud. Näiteks kujutame ette, et mina tegin faili indeks. Kaks Html Lihtsalt mängime, Teie tegite. Ka mina panin. Vaata, Kit. I, Vaata, palun. Aa, järgi seda. Html kahte. Vaata, onju. Ja kui mitte nende haarusse, ära, teie Tegite selle faili ka, Näiteks, onju? Aga te ei pannud isegi Kit ad iga, et teda jälgitakse,
Õpetaja: siis on niimoodi et Changes I alt Võite ta siit ära saada, Aga see fail füüsiliselt on ikka teie arvutis. Kui teie nüüd tahate, võtta nagu minu arust
Õpetaja: tahate võtta uut Haru. Siis tuleb Clash, et selles harus õpetaja Harus on Html kaks. Sinul on samamoodi Html. Kaks
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole jälgimises, aga ta on samas kaustas. Ja sama faili nimi. Ta ei saa aktiivselt minna nagu selle minu niiöelda harukoopia peale, mis te just võtsite, kuna seal tekib Lihtsalt konflikt. Vaata, mida kuradit ma sellega teen. Ehk siis see peaks nägema välja Niukene. Tühjus peaks siin olema. Mitte midagi ei tohiks siin olla
Õpetaja: lihtsam ongi siis selekteerida See fail vajutada. Näiteks siit Rolbacki tuleb üks uus aken. Vaata veel lahti. Vaatad siit ka, et kõik failid on sinised tikid. Tegelikult vist ei loe midagi. Justkui,
Õpetaja: ee. Ja siis vajutad Rolback.
Õpetaja: Kõik, kes tahavad nüüd jälgida tulla. Palun tehke. Seda Tulge oma olemasolevad. Kõige lihtsam on tetroeter all Back.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on teil see eeldus on olemas, et kui võtta uus haru õpetaja pealt ja minna selle haru peale. Siis Teil ei teki mingisuguseid konflikte ega probleeme. Ja kõik saab minema nagu Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: kustuta üles klikk peale delete,
Õpetaja: sul ei Ole vaja. Vaata. Sa tuled niikuinii sellele seisule. Vaata, kus on kõik need failid, mis minul on Ja mitte midagi rohkem mitte midagi vähem,
Õpetaja: nüüd kõike nagu sealt vä peabki kaduma. Kõik ära Aga selles see mõte oligi.
Õpetaja: Ee, see mõte. On Praegult see. Vaata, Kujutame ette, et Angeliina, et sul praegu. Sa tahtsid minule järgi tulla. Vaata, sa oled maasmust. Sul on mingi viga seal sees, või mida iganes, on ju See roll, Back. Seda teebki. Kõik sinu muudatused. Aa kaovad ära. Lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ja see kõik su failid on täpselt sellises seisus nagu oli viimane konkreetse faili suhtes. Vaata,
Õpetaja: sul ei ole lahtiseid muudatusi Ongi siis tekkinud. Niimoodi. Näiteks see on näiteks see kaart.
Õpetaja: See Ongi see koht, et Sina Ei, Copi Based isid kaardi. Ee, failis, et selle pildi faili projekti, onju? Tol hetkel ta tegelikult küsis su käest, et kas ma Lisan jälgimisse. Vaata sealt. Kas siis ristiga kinni või pole tähtis? Kuidas Vaata aga ta ei olnudki. Personeerimises
Õpetaja: all on muudatused kõik need failid, Mis on antud jälgimiseks,
Õpetaja: on see, et mina ei jälgi. Tee, mis tahad. Tahad teha mingi ajutist, faili, Midagi Midagi teed, kirjutad seal, mida iganes. Sa võid teha seda seal projektis. Ja sa ei soovigi, et näiteks sinna nagu, noh, läheks pilve nagu niiöelda ka onju
Õpetaja: aga Roll Back täpselt seda teebki Ta taastab sellise seisu, mis oli kõige viimase komiteega. Kui sina tegid vahepeal tööd, siis ta läks korstnas,
Õpetaja: siis sa Saad teha paremaid. Just, ja ad. Vaata, et. Noh, see. See juhtub pidevalt. On see, et meil tekivad uued jaavaklassid ja failid, Vaata, läheb. Pidevalt mööda. Vaata, on ju,
Õpetaja: et kui sa näed nagu seal. Vot selles mõttes, iga kord, kui sa teed mingit tööd varem või hiljem Sa lähed selle kommit tööriista alla, et neid ära kommit, ida. Ja kui sa sealt teedki mingisugused punased failid, vaata siis sa lihtsalt kõikid nende peale ja ütled.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta on nagu. Okei, see on versioneerimisest. Kui sa nüüd vaata, siis see läheb sinna. Haarusse, kus pea sa hetkel oled, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga praegult see mõte oligi. Just see. Vaata, et ma õpetan, kuidas te saate järgi tulla, aga see on Eeldus, et mitte midagi pooleliolevat ei ole. Sellepärast see tekitab probleeme Sellel hetkel, kui te võtate uue haaru minult ja tehakse automaatselt Checkout
Õpetaja: ja Seal tekib klass nende failidega. Mis teil on lahti ja mis on minul? Vaata
Õpetaja: et siis. Ee, need sammud, mis on on see ee, Kipp tööriistast. Kõik puhtaks.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla järgmine samm? Pakkuge,
Õpetaja: Mina just tegin Comiti. Vaata ühe sekund tagasi või vaata sellepärast, Kui praegult teie tuleksite. Võtaksite siit Remote I alt.
Õpetaja: Aa. Noh, te võtaksite seda siit, aga mul on parem näidata seda. No te tahate sellest Tahate uut haru võtta. New Branch From Origin õpetaja ideaalist võtta. See, mis on Remote ist, mitte lokalist. Siis ju. Praegult. On seis see, et see Remodi Seis. On ju viimane peegeldus,
Õpetaja: mis? Ma tegin Mingi tund, et siin selles õpetajas ei ole seda komiiti, mis mina just tegin potentsiaalselt. No minul on. Ma ei saa näidata. Vaata, kui teie lähete õpetaja peale. Kas seal on Lisa? Siin Asju
Õpetaja: ei ole ja kui sa tuleksid, võtaksid siit ülevalt. Remote õpetaja Checkout. New Branch on ju? Siis ta võtaks täpselt selle seisuga. Siis on iga kord plats puhtaks
Õpetaja: ja Alles siis,
Õpetaja: kui fetsh on. Nagu näete, siin all on suht Kiirelt läheb ta ära alles siis, kui see fetš on niiöelda ära tehtud, Vot siis on see hetk, kus te tulete. Remote?
Õpetaja: Õpetaja New Branch nimi. Sidekriips V. Kaks, Näiteks Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt alati need sammud on kõigepealt alati es puhtaks.
Õpetaja: Roll Back Id on kõige lihtsam fetš.
Õpetaja: Ja siis õpetaja pealt ja mitte selle lokali alt. Kui teil teil lokalit üldse. Õpetajaid ei peakski olema.
Õpetaja: Aga remoodi all või mitte?
Õpetaja: Jah, Remody all on pilves. On ikka
Õpetaja: Logan. See peagi olema. See ei Tööta minu halus.
Õpetaja: Mis on siin samal ajal?
Õpetaja: Aga see on projekt. Su haru on siin.
Õpetaja: Üks asi ka. Vaatasin. Jah Võite korra nüüd Hästi, täpselt selle tekstil. Ikka.
Õpetaja: See on natukene häiriv. Vaata, jah, Rita ja Master. Täpselt nii, nagu on sul oli alla.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see
Õpetaja: Kuule, aga jah, ma ei ole mulle üldse ei tea. Vaata, see on
Õpetaja: taustal. Teeb seda. Vaata, kui siit on näha nagu Joon tegi ära. Jah, mis on? Ee,
Õpetaja: jah, see sama nimi on kolmekene.
Õpetaja: Ei, seda praetan lihtsalt uue ja midagi muud teis ilma peale
Õpetaja: nii saite sellega hakkama. Ja mis te nüüd on, on see, kui te teete Browser I lahti siis on igal juhul teil see,
Õpetaja: ee, sama seesmismeel sellele.
Õpetaja: Ja kui te teete selle padlet I lahti. Ma ei tea, kas ma panin kuskile selle urli ka või mitte,
Õpetaja: sai taini url Vali idee.
Õpetaja: Siin on eraldi pandud siia juurde. Ka õpetus.
Õpetaja: Catch Mef you Can Rainile. Kiirelt järgi jõudmine. Mis need sammud on? Lihtsalt loomulikult,
Õpetaja: et siin, ta räägib ära, et need võib nagu ära õppida. Vaata, et vali kõik muudatused failiga.
Õpetaja: Aa, seda tikki ma tegelikult ei sooviks, Sellepärast Talle jääb meelde see teinekord. Tahad midagi kustutada? Ei taha, siis ta räägib seda. Unversion files. Kustuta ära.
Õpetaja: Fets otsi ee niiöelda remont I alt. Aa, Mul oli nimi Rain, Aga ma olen viimasel ajal lihtsalt õpetaja.
Õpetaja: Sest et ükskord oli ka veel üks Rain,
Õpetaja: tegelt ei Ole palju. Saame toolist. Lihtsalt vaatate et on plats. Puhas fetš Õpetaja, New Branch kõik
Õpetaja: ja ma ütlengi, et teeme, nagu ma teen selle teile nii lihtsaks. Vaata, et ainukene. Asi on lihtsalt öelda Rain T. Üks kommit.
Õpetaja: See tähendab minu jaoks seda, et kui mind push, on ju.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: ma küsin, kas ee. On keegi, veel, kes nagu tuleb järgi käsi püsti Ühtegi kätt ei näe, liigume edasi, Sobib teile selline asi.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, kellel on juba näiteks Cloud Code või mõni muu niiöelda terminal, siis siin. Ee, tegelikult on olemas ka skill. Aa catch Up Feature Branch.
Õpetaja: Mis tegelikult on siis see, et ee.
Õpetaja: Õpetaja harule järgi jõudmine
Õpetaja: tuvast hetkel haru, mille peal oled. Tühista lahtised muudatused kustutamata Otsi õpetaja arenduse. Harulous. Haru, haruld, bla blabla.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult seda see niiöelda Agent saab ka selle teie eest ära teha,
Õpetaja: aga need on nii paar klikki, et sa tegelt ei ole.
Õpetaja: Teete kiiremini ära. Ta hakkab kõigepealt jeppima. Veel midagi? Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, lähme edasi. Kas rekord on peal? On pileke. Vist on küll
Õpetaja: proovida. Oli Jah, nagu sa. Kui sa olid järjel. Sa ei pea tegema seda. See mõte oli lihtsalt see, Kes tahab tulla? Kas on keegi, kes tahab veel Järgi tulla? Käsi püsti.
Õpetaja: See tegelt. Ee, ma tuletan meelde ka. Ee, see praegult. Mida Me kõik teeme on selles mõttes täielikult prügikasti kaup, Et Ee, me ainult harjutame. Noh, isegi ei harjuta. Me vaatame neid võimalusi ja üritame aru saada, kuidas need võimalused töötavad
Õpetaja: ja kõik muud, mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Täna ei pea isegi veel midagi. Otseselt nagu nii hullult klõbistama. Sellepärast, et See nagu iseenesest ei ole nii tähtis. Aga muidugi võimalus. Klõbistage alati kaasa Sellepärast, et, ee. Ütleme niimoodi. Mida halvemini teil tegelikult see klõbistamine välja tuleb. Seda Paremaks Saab minna, klõbistades ainult
Õpetaja: üldse progemine. Ka progemist saab kõige paremini ee paremaks saada. Siis kui proged midagi järjekordse video Ja teksti lugemine ei ole niivõrd abistav progemisel kui mingi asja Kallal nokitsemine ja progemine its The Best Harjutame nende meistriks, mäletate?
Õpetaja: Võibolla Aa Rainbow Brackets ka. Ee, okei,
Õpetaja: aa. Vaadake, kui kellegil. Võibolla on see peal Kellegil mitte. Ma ei tea, kuidas nüüd on kui teha see Sama Html fail lahti.
Õpetaja: Mul tuleks kinni nüüd sealt.
Õpetaja: Kas teil on kõik värvid? Ee, kollased või vähemalt ühevärvilised. Vahet pole, mis värvi nad on või on värvilised.
Õpetaja: Minul on nad kõik ühte värvi. Need tekstid siin need tagid. On teil ka ühte värvi
Õpetaja: et tegelikult taustal Ee, Autoinstalleriga Installiti ära Üks Plugin
Õpetaja: Ee. Pluginate jaoks. Ee Soovitan minna Hammasrattale
Õpetaja: ja Plugins.
Õpetaja: Kas te näete seda Rainbow Regat?
Õpetaja: Siin See on Install Tal, Vaata, kui te. Ma teen need sammud uuesti. Hammasratas.
Õpetaja: Bloggins
Õpetaja: ja all on näha Vaata, need Rainbow Brackets. Need installer installis teile meid. Tegelikult huvitab see Rainbow Brackets, mis ee värvib koodi siin pilti ühtegi ei ole. Näe. On. Vaata, et ta värvib koodi ja eriti just Need sulud ja asjad skoobid.
Õpetaja: Kust mingi asi algab? Kust mingi asi lõpeb? Erivärvi
Õpetaja: et on, Jumala hea vaadata nagu kui asjad on üksteise sees, kus mingi asi algab ja kus mingi asi lõpeb. Aga tundub, et on ära installitud. Ta mul siin küsib. Mingit update Selle update Iga ma hetkel ei vaeva. Või noh, võib selle update I teha aga restart I ma ei kavatse teha igal juhul sellega ta võib minna. Põrgu
Õpetaja: update võib teha järgmine kord siis, kui teed intellige lahti, siis on see update adversion.
Õpetaja: Mis seal ikka nii väga uut on,
Õpetaja: Väga hea, mulle meeldib õudsalt. See blogin.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, iseenesest. Ee, sellega on kõik.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Mingil põhjusel. On Niuke, tunne et ta aktiveeritud ei ole. Sa näed restart Ide seda ma väldiks, et ju praegu tekste ei ole, et ta võibolla mingi hetk küsiks, kas Enable It jah Või Ei üleval. Kui kellegil on see kiri veel ees. Enable Mingi Rainbow Bracket, siis pange enable.
Õpetaja: Seal. Muidugi võib restart juba siis vaja minna. Muidugi ma hakkan mõtlema. Kohe saame teada. Ee, aga muidu mingil põhjusel mulda ei ole, Siis ma otsin Settings setting sealt ma otsin Rainbow,
Õpetaja: mitte Rambo, vaid Rainbow.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on Rainbow Brackets, mitte pluginate all, vaid siin eraldi. Ee, siin on Rainbow Brackets,
Õpetaja: Ee, Enable. Enable Aa, kuskil peaks olema võimalik. Siis
Õpetaja: ee. Panna kirja ka. Kus Ja millal?
Õpetaja: Vot nii näete Seda
Õpetaja: Siit on see, et ta Html is ka oleks peal,
Õpetaja: siis peab selle tiki sisse panema.
Õpetaja: Check the Screenshot. Sest näed, ta näitab. Siin on mingid pildid. Arvatavasti et. Ee, enne
Õpetaja: Vaadake, see on siin. Ee, värvitud. Vaata, meil Näete, see algab ja lõpeb siin.
Õpetaja: See algab. Lõpeb? Siin. Saate mõttes aru, kuidas see toimib.
Õpetaja: Päris hea asi. Paneme selle sisse, paneme Apply ja Okei, Ja minul Vähemalt nüüd muutus.
Õpetaja: Kui kellegil on nüüd veits erinevad värvid või mingi Väga vikerkaar. Siis on veel mingi üks setting, kus seda mingi valib? Igasuguseid suvalisi värve. Aga suures pildis peaks vist olema samad värvid nüüd Teil nagu mul
Õpetaja: kuidagi täpselt samad värvid. Aga see süsteem töötab. Siis on kõik hästi.
Õpetaja: Vaata, siin on roheline. Need Kõik on Aa, räägime Nüüd natukene relationship is. Ka meil kõigile meeldivad Relationship Id.
Õpetaja: See element siit ja siiani.
Õpetaja: See on hetkel pärend.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tablatuuriga on nagu näha, et tema sees on meta. Mis on meta sellele head elemendile?
Õpetaja: Sugulussuhtes, Child.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme otsime näiteks table.
Õpetaja: Kes on dr Table Ile?
Õpetaja: Mhmh, Kes on see,
Õpetaja: Jah, Crunchide lapselaps, onju?
Õpetaja: Okei, kes on see? Ja no võtame siit altpoolt parem. Kes on see ja see, kes nad on omavahel
Õpetaja: vot paar.
Õpetaja: Okei, päris hea
Õpetaja: sugulased. Aga ütleme, ütleme nii, et inglise keeles on see Eesti keeles. Peab teistmoodi ütlema, õed vennad,
Õpetaja: Nad on selle sama lapsed, on ju?
Õpetaja: See on teibilaps Ja see on teibilaps, onju?
Õpetaja: No me mingi nõstama ei hakka, kes on see Ja see siin on mingid mingid onud Ja need on ju mõttest, saate aru? Siin on selline hierarhia ja see Rainbow niiöelda seda peegeldab meil progemisel Ja kui hiljem teeme asju, muutub see ka tähtsaks, et me saame sugulussuhetest aru
Õpetaja: Eelkõige siis see Child Parent, Grand Parent, bla, Bla bla, midagi Nii Okei,
Õpetaja: aga lähme edasi. Kuhu me jäime? Me jäime input I juurde. Kus meil oli siis tehtud? Ee, üks
Õpetaja: üks Kast ära tehtud, eesnimi. Teeme siia veits juurde. Neid
Õpetaja: õppisime Ka seda. Et Aa, käime Id juurde Me panime input Ile kirja, Vaata, et See kast
Õpetaja: edaspidi koodi mõttes on first name. Näete, Id
Õpetaja: Sellel kastil on oma identifikaator Id ja see on First Name.
Õpetaja: See on viimane, Asi, mis ma tegin Nüüd see label on selline elukas, kes tegelikult ee nõuab. See on silt. Silt saab olla mingisugusele kastile
Õpetaja: ja see Foor. Nüüd peaks olema nagu see, et. Aga kellele see on?
Õpetaja: No kelle label see on? Jah, me viisa. Me näeme, et see visuaalselt on siin niimoodi. Nad on koos omavahel, on ju? On see label sellele kastile?
Õpetaja: Aga see on lihtsalt visuaalselt teine asi on, see kuidas ta, nagu, Aa programmiliselt. Justkui on
Õpetaja: siin foori sees. Me saamegi öelda, et see thislabel East for No mis ma siia sisse kirjutan
Õpetaja: Panete, Näete, juba aitab, et. Aa, kas sa mõtled First Name I. Noh, Tabiga saaks valida
Õpetaja: Need asjad on nüüd omavahel seotud, kui te hoiate Kontrollid peal
Õpetaja: ja hiirega tuletab First name i peale Ta muutub hüperlingiks,
Õpetaja: kui ma klikin selle, peale, mis te arvate, kuhu mul see kursor Lendab siia
Õpetaja: ja vastupidi. Kui Ma klikin praegu. Aa, siia poole. Niipidi Ta ei ole. Klikitab ainult niipidi. Siin Kontekstis on saate mõttes aru. No ma panen ta eemale. Üksteisest
Õpetaja: on mõte, selge?
Õpetaja: Nii okei, et see on Niukene hea tava. Labli puhul. Jah, ei pea
Õpetaja: nagu selles mõttes. Atribuudid võivad olla mistahes järjekorras. Tehnilises mõttes.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Ei, atribuudid võivad olla mis tahes järjekorras. Ma võin panna siia Style Blocki. Näiteks, Kas ta on siin.
Õpetaja: Kas ta on siin?
Õpetaja: Kas ta on topelt? Seda ma ei tea, See Vist on näiteks kahtlane juba, on ju? Ei Ole aga, ee, aga see ei tähenda. Ee, see on nüüd tehniline aspekt, mis ma ütlesin. Järjekord on savi,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd koodi tava, käekiri, Ja niiöelda, uniform, et kõik oleks sarnane. Käekiri peaks olema sama kui ikka projektis. Kogu aeg pannakse neid kuskile lõppu või ette või keskele,
Õpetaja: Siis nad peaksid samamoodi jätkama. Vaadake, probleem on nagu see, et ee, inimesed on erinevad ja inimestel on erinevad stiilid ja ja mõtted. Kuidas Ühte või teist asja teha. Koodibaas ei ole see koht, kus väljendada oma seda ekspressiivsust kui lahedalt sina oskad nagu kõike asju nagu vormindada Ja teha
Õpetaja: koodi. Baasis on ikkagi niimoodi, et käekiri peaks olema läbivalt kogu aeg niivõrd samasugune kui vähegi, võimalik,
Õpetaja: arvestades sinna juurde ka siis, Et Noh, sa võibolla sadades. Aa, isegi sadades võib olla neid inimesi, kes Aa seda projekti, nagu teevad. Võibolla mitte nagu tänases päevas, aga läbi ajaloo. Kui sul on rakendus, mis on kümme aastat vana tegemist on mingi suure rakendusega arendusmeeskond. On ju kui. Palju inimesi on kümne aasta jooksul käinud sellest koodist üle.
Õpetaja: Kui igaüks paneks nagu mingi oma stiili, nagu siis see asi oleks väga nasty, et, ee, et see ei tähenda seda, et kus tehniline asi. Võibolla mingeid piiranguid ei sea. Siis Clean Code räägib ikkagi sellest, et Koodibaas peaks olema tegelikult samasuguse käekirjaga.
Õpetaja: Ja tavaliselt on niimoodi, et mingisugused siuksed Suuremad asjad on tegelikult meeskondlikult kokkuleppes olemas. Juba
Õpetaja: lepitakse kokku kuidas tehakse asju, Teised asjad tulevad Keeles ka, näiteks jaavas.
Õpetaja: Tehniliselt pole vahet, kas kõigepealt tuleb meetod, Siis tuleb private meetod.
Õpetaja: Kui on private meetod, siis tuleb meetod, on, et Seal miksitud Igatepidi tehnilises võitis pole see nagu Jumala savi. Ta töötab, kompileeritakse bike koodiks. Sellepärast Ongi see võibolla, kus iganes ee seal on, Nagu see kompileeritud kood. Just seda teebki. Vaata, et ee, Selle järjekord on üli savi,
Õpetaja: Aga jaavas on ikkagi öeldud. Niimoodi, et meetodid tulevad Kõigepealt meetodid tulevad alles siis, kui kõik public meetod on otsas, et see tegelikult ei ole mingi naiskäekiri, vaid see on selle keele poolt ette öeldud, et see on tava Konvention
Õpetaja: Konventsioonidega tuleb ka arvestada. Vaata, meelis on ka kindlasti konventsioon, et kui praegu Chatilt küsida, vaata. Kus peaks see Id olema, nagu on ju? Vaata, Siis ta nagu ütleks sulle, et jah. Võibolla tehakse nii ja naa, aga nagu tava, nagu Nii, vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd see asi on ka. See. Vaata, et, ee, kõike tavalisi ei pea järgima. Mida, Ee, näiteks Claud ütleb Näiteks või mis iganes või mis on.
Õpetaja: Kui meeskond ikka otsustab, et meile meeldib teha sellist tava, siis see on meie meeskondlik otsus ja See on Fine. Ja nüüd ongi lihtsalt see, et meeskond peab sellest kinni hoidma.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see päriselus välja näeb? Ongi see, et kui sa Lähed kuskile tööle. Seal ongi see. Te ei lähe niukest projekti tegema, et alustate nullist mingi pangaautomaate lehte tegema, vaid te hakkate seal tegema Mingit süsteemi muudatust mingisuguses
Õpetaja: projektis, mis on juba mitmeid aastaid niiöelda kestnud. Te teete juurde midagi. Seal on, Siis ongi see, et te peate Nagu veits. Nagu vaatama koodi baasis ümber. Kui ei ole selge? Vaata kohe,
Õpetaja: et ee, kuidas? On nagu tava mõningate asjadega, mis tehnilises mõttes on Igatepidi võivad olla. Noh, sul on koodibaas ees.
Õpetaja: Vaatad seal mingi failiasju? Saad kohe pildi. Ette. Vaatab see tava on Kui on mingi Küsimus Siis küsiks kolleegilt, et kuidas me. Kuidas me teeme?
Õpetaja: Või noh, siis hiljemalt. Code Reviewst hakkab teil asju tulema, Aa, nii öelda, et Kuule, sa tegid nagu mingi asja. Jah, tehniliselt see on kõik korrektne, aga me tegelikult nagu teeme natuke. Teistmoodi Tavaliselt, on ju et varem Või hiljem põrkad sellega nii mina kokku.
Õpetaja: Ja Nende Ai tööriistadega on ka väga lihtne. Juhendit saab neile anda, kohe mis nad ise sisse vajavad. Nad ei hakka koodi enne genereerima, kui nad juba teavad. Vaata, kuidas sina tahad asju, kui hästi ta juhendit oskab lugeda. Muidugi on ise küsimusi vaadatud ta võib olla perfektselt. Seda ikka ei tee,
Õpetaja: aga lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Aa, et Id võib olla selles mõttes kus iganes. Me Hakkame tegema seda panga projekti. Seda päris projekti Ka siis me ka. On otsustuskohad siin seal, et kus järjekorda jätame ja üritame hoida nagu Samat joont. Aa, tüütu on lihtsalt see, kui kuskil
Õpetaja: pikk Mingit aega oled teinud. Mingit uut projekti. Ühel hetkel sa nagu hakkad mõtlema ümbert.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult Mulle ei meeldi see stiil, mis ma olen valinud ja ma tahaks ikkagi minna mingi teist stiili. Siis on küsimus. Kaks varianti. Kas Me tõmbame täna nagu jooneliiva peale ja ütleme, et siit edasi teeme. Teist stiili. Vanaasja ei puutu või teeme vana asja ka ühtlaseks sama Stiiliga. See on siis
Õpetaja: otsus kui ise teed mingit projekti. On Samamoodi otsus. Vaata, et kas ma hakkan näpi meie korda tegema või mitte,
Õpetaja: Või Ei hakka. Noh, kuna meil on see Ai asjad, siis arvatavasti saaks tegelikult niuksed. Niisugused muudatused saaks tegelt teha suht lihtsa vaevaga
Õpetaja: ee ära. Ja kui unitest Id on all, siis võibolla ei lähe midagi katki ka,
Õpetaja: et, ee, et. Aga, noh, mingid meetodi nimed ja stiilid, Noh, seal võib ikkagi olla. Mida, mis nõuaks? Nagu natukene Nagu tööd ka. Vaata, et kui päriselt teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina olen kogenud seda mõlemat pidi on Lhv S olnud niimoodi, et Davai teeme veits vanu asju ümber, Lähme uues suunas ja on olnud niimoodi, et, lihtsalt, ee, nüüd Kui teeme uusi, asju, siis teeme nii,
Õpetaja: et nagu vanad asjad kunagi. Võibolla pika aja jooksul
Õpetaja: kaovad või muutuvad. Ee, või noh, kui sa Lähed kuskile midagi muutuma, muutma ja tegema siis sa teed selle asja ka korda. Mis sul silma jääb, onju?
Õpetaja: Kuidagi, nii
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme nüüd seda sama asja uuesti. Aa, see first name iga. Aga teeme niimoodi, et. Ee esiteks paneme Break I siia.
Õpetaja: Paneme Jah, piisab ja paneme Tublitseerime seda. Eesnime asja ja ühe korra veel Vaatame, kuidas ta jäi.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd muudame lihtsalt ära. Ee ei ole, mitte first name, vaid on last, Name.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Okei, Ma seda ei saa praegu näidata. Veel, aga varsti saan. Paneme siia ka.
Õpetaja: Copy on sulle ja mitte eestnimi, vaid
Õpetaja: shift I. Oled all. Kirjutad siia? Tere, pere konnanimi.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tulnud mitte välja nii,
Õpetaja: noh, siis peaks tulema midagi taolist nii väga Hästi, teeme. Veel.
Õpetaja: Me Teeme sellest ka tublikaadi. Võtame selle preigi sinna sisse, et on niimoodi kohe olemas.
Õpetaja: No See, viimane võiks olla age Vanus
Õpetaja: selle võib teha siniseks valitud a tähtaja ja valida H. Vahet pole, kuidas.
Õpetaja: No tuleme siis midagi taolist, aga nüüd on üks konks,
Õpetaja: Noh, senikaua kuni teinud trükite seal.
Õpetaja: Mina võin teha.
Õpetaja: Siia saan panna. Aa, saan siia. Saan panna. Aa, saan
Õpetaja: siia saab panna. Aa, saan, Aga siia ei tahaks vist, et saaks. Aha, panna.
Õpetaja: Miks? Sest et see peaks olema
Õpetaja: number? Aga kui me nüüd vaatame seda input i See atribuut. Neid kaste on igasuguseid. Siin on taipand. Tekst.
Õpetaja: Meie võiks siin panna hoopis number.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma nüüd tulen siia, sisse üritan klõbistada.
Õpetaja: Aa, või mingeid muid ei saa. Kui ma panen numbreid, siis saab,
Õpetaja: saate mõttest aru. Meil meil ei ole nagu input eraldi input, Ee, elemente. Mingi miljon tükki. Vaid Meil on atribuudiga omadus.
Õpetaja: See on number. Noh, ma panen näiteks selle eesnime Panen näiteks korraks muudan ära Ja panen hoopis.
Õpetaja: Mm on Password.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma kirjutan eesnime siis ei näe midagi,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen. Noh, ma sellega praegu mängin. Vaata, onju, Kui ma panen Date,
Õpetaja: siis ta on Niukene kastikene, mille peale saad klikkida ja Valida. Ühe kuupäeva aru. Neid on palju,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, Kas checkbox oli ka checkbox?
Õpetaja: Noh, kastist muutus hoopis tikkpoks, eks
Õpetaja: Ei ole eraldi elementi, vaid on lihtsalt input i atribuudiga.
Õpetaja: Kuidas jah,
Õpetaja: jah, Aga kus siis? Aga kui on eesnimi? Panen tiki ära. Et on eesnimi, kus ma olen? Rains on panna.
Õpetaja: Ei panegi Pole pole
Õpetaja: ja See on lisame Uue pangakliendil. Pole kellegi asi salastatud. No ma panen. Ma panen selle tekstiks tagasi. Nüüd Ennem, kui mul meelest ära läheb. Siis järgmine asi on Place Holder.
Õpetaja: Sellel input Il on veel üks atribuut nimega. Mis see võiks olla vahet vahe,
Õpetaja: Jah, see on juba Parem selgitada, eks? Meil sa pead olema Aga tegelikult pigem on. Ee. Asukohad. Täitja oleks nagu otsatõlge, on ju? Noh, kui mul oleks eesnimi, Öelge mulle üks kõige klassikalisem eise perekonnanimi, mis on kõige enam levinud
Õpetaja: ee Eesti mehe. Nimi. Okei, Alekseid asjad. Jätame. Võtame. Klassikalise
Õpetaja: Mart tamm Inglise keeles. Võibolla John Smith.
Õpetaja: Vot selle kontseptsiooniga. Tuttavad
Õpetaja: on see, et siia sisse saaks panna mingi teksti, mis on näide, aga see ei Ole see kasti sisu ise. Et kui ma panen, ma panen siia Mart,
Õpetaja: siis näete, on Hallilt Mart,
Õpetaja: aga ma klikin siia peale see See ei ole siin ei ole sisu. Mart, praegu. See on tühi on praegu.
Õpetaja: Kui ma kirjutan siia rainopis, siis nii on nii
Õpetaja: siis Ee, ma saaksin siia perekonnanimele panna. Ka näiteks panen Tamb siis on niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Marta on mees. Ma tean, nagu, umbes, mida kirjutada
Õpetaja: Nüüd uis võib tihtipeale teha niukest triki, aga ma kohe selgitan. Ära vaata, et
Õpetaja: ee, mina. Mina vihkan. Ee, Kui minnakse seda stiili ja tegemist on vormiga, kus on väga palju välju. Eriti kui mingid tekstehäired ja asjad. Ma nüüd näitan Teile võib ju nii teha, näiteks, et siin ma Panen hoopis selleks Playstorder Iks Panen eesnimi
Õpetaja: eesnimi ja seda label it üldse ei kasuta.
Õpetaja: Olete näinud niukest ee. Kasutajaliidest niukest onju eesnimi ja Nii edasi. See on kõik väga Fine. Aga senikaua on see minu meelest fine, Kui sinna sisse käib, Tõeliselt äratuntav sisu. Selle sisu enda järgi.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen seda, et kui sul on nüüd nagu, ee, tuhat kasti
Õpetaja: Ee. Mõned on võibolla mingid suuremad kastid ja väiksemad kastid, kus saab rohkem tekstid. Ja vähem on ju? Kui sa mingi hetk nagu täidad kõik asjad ära, vaata, siis sa enam ei näe,
Õpetaja: aga ühel Hetkel võib sul hakata kahtlusi usse vaatama, kas ma olen kõik täitnud õigesti õigetesse lahtritesse, sest et see info kaob ära, et mulle isiklikult See huvi ei meeldi. See on fine. Kui sa oled mingi sisse logimine, usernane password ja nii edasi noh,
Õpetaja: tärnidega. Ja kus on nagu Mingid mõned niuksed asjad, mingi. Äkki suudad need paar välja ära täita niimoodi, et sa nagu mõttega täidad need ära, on ju Aga kui Me räägime ikka vormist. Vaata, kus on ikka Palju välja siis Minu meelest see ei ole hea mõte.
Õpetaja: Eriti numbrilised väärtused. Näiteks oleks meil Kast Võibolla, Kus saab panna koordinaadid? Üks on teine on. Täidad numbritega ära.
Õpetaja: Kum. Kumb oli,
Õpetaja: et ee, natukene peab olema ettevaatlik A ja by The way oi Ma, Ma. Panen mõelnud emaili kirjutada
Õpetaja: uue uue niiöelda konto regamine koos parooliga
Õpetaja: kui. Sul on password Box Password Box on alati tavaliselt vaikimis, et on. Ei, Näe, vaata, mis kirjutab.
Õpetaja: Kui sa teed. Aa, nii öelda Password i lisamine siis sul peaks olema Kaks kasti. Üks on ja teine on põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: kontrollparood. Vaata kui mõinna on kuskil uude kohta regata parooli
Õpetaja: Aa, regad. Vaata Paned oma mingi lemmik parooli ära. Siis peab olema sada viiskümmend tähte pikk, Vaata, onju? Paned selle ära? Peab olema üks special karakter. Vaata, on ju okei, Kuusteist tähemärki. Tavaliselt on. Kaksteist on ju kaksteist tähemärki. Peab väikseid tähti suuri tähte asju on ju Tooksid selle asja valmis? Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: Siis nagu mõtled, nagu. Vau, et kas ma kuskil slippisin või mitte? Kui seda kontrolli ei ole, siis ma olen näinud niukseid uudiseid ja Mind ajab lihtsalt närvi, et siis ma mingi lahti tegema hakkan. Seal toksima. Sa võtad kogu see. Mõte, Keegi näeb mu ekraani kõrvalt või läbi. Kuidagi interneti on siis äkkinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, näeb kuidagi. Mind, Onju Või mis iganes, et siis ma pean ikka minema. Naine kõrval vaatab mu Seda standard parool I on ju. Nagu ma ei saa, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma ei ole ju kindel, nagu. Et niipea kui ma Enter vajutan, siis See parool on, on ju? Pärast on see ka. Vaata, et klassikaliselt väga klassikaliselt normaalsed rakendused. Minu meelest teevad seda, et kui sa lood uue konto. Siis sa ei ole kohe sisse logitud, vaid ta suunab sind lehele ja pead kohe nagu toksima. Nüüd sa lähed sinna lehele, Siis hakkad toksima. Vaatad ei ole. See Võtke nagu.
Õpetaja: Okei, ma pean. Ma alles just regasin siia kontole. Ma pean hakkama seda nagu protseduuri läbi tegema. See. See on natuke Niukene Professionaalne Kretinism ka. Vaata, et tegelikult, sa. Kui sa teed niukest tarkvara arendust, siis sa hakkad igasuguseid asju märkama.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis tegelikult sind hakkad häirima? Sest sa mõtled, et mina niimoodi ei teeks? Mobiili jaoks. Nüüd tehakse täitsa teine versioon.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei tehtud Csss iga tingimata. Kui me räägime nagu see skaleeritavus, siis see on Csss iga küll ja. Aga nagu mingi täiesti teistsuguse visuaali nägemine. See ei ole enam. See on juba
Õpetaja: selles mõttes, et ma toon teile näite. Vaata, on ju, et desktopil võibolla on väga ee, Timm näha mingeid asju justkui tabeli kujul.
Õpetaja: Võibolla mobiilid seda nagu väikeste ruutude kaartidega. Näha, onju et niukseid asju saad sa teha nagu jalas programmeerimisega. Aga kui me räägime seda? Vaata, kuidas asjad nagu skaleeriksid, siis see on tehtud Csiga ja tehakse niuksed sätted, kuhu Ccs I pannakse Kirja erinevad nagu vahemikud.
Õpetaja: See Laiuse järgi käib see alati kõrguse järgi. Formaate on nii erinevad, on ju? Laiuse järgi käib tavaliselt niimoodi, et Kui kasutaja ekraan läheb niiöelda väiksemaks. Kui see siis järsku rakenduvad teistsugused stiilisäpped.
Õpetaja: Kui ta on suurem ja nii edasi, et see on, nagu See ütleme siis. No. Tänapäeval on üldse nagu Mobile First. Vaata, nagu mõtlemine, et eelkõige tegelikult disainitaksegi seda asja nagu Aa mobiili jaoks, ja Siis nagu
Õpetaja: kui ta juba mobiilil näitab. Hästi, siis küll ta seal desktop Il ka näitab hästi, aga saab ka teha täiesti. Niimoodi, et nagu Siga ja kägu
Õpetaja: ta saab. Aru Vaata, kui see vaade läheb väga väikseks siis näita hoopis teistmoodi. See on nagu programmeerimine. Kõik on tehtav. Aa by the way Kui. Keegi küsib mu käest ikka küsitakse mu käest räägin kuule. Aga, kas niimoodi on võimalik me? Räägime programmeerimisest Siis ma alati ütlen. Programmeerimises on kõik võimalik. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt pole. Ainult see fantaasia on põhimõtteliselt põhimõtteliselt, mis on pidurdav tegur ühel või teisel viisil. Mingil kujul on realiseeritav. Kõik asjad on ju Aga mul on üks teine väljend ka selle kohta. Kui keegi küsib, vaata, et Rain, kas See, on võimalik, Siis ma ütlen alati niimoodi. Mu sõber kunagi ütles seda. Vaata niimoodi, et ühe inimese seest tuleb välja teine inimene
Õpetaja: Ja elus on kõik võimalik. Noh, tühja koha pealt.
Õpetaja: Jah, et, ee, kõik on võimalik.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles mõttes piire. Ei ole ainult fantaasia on piirid.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga tuleme selle juurde. Tagasi Nüüd see vanus on olemas. Nüüd on niimoodi, et Ee numbrit Ta võtab ainukene täht, mis ta võtab, on E.
Õpetaja: Miks Eed võtab? Miks ta eed võtab? Sisse. Eksponent on ju?
Õpetaja: Saab, aga põhimõtteliselt Ja nüüd tegelikult ma ütlen kohe ära. Pole Vahet, mis sa siin iks võtad. Kui sa võtaksid programmiliselt siit andmeid, siis ta tuleb alati ikkagi Tekstina String Lihtsalt teadmiseks,
Õpetaja: et taustal Tegelikult on ikkagi tekst
Õpetaja: siin sees. Lihtsalt see browser, nagu ise. Nagu keelab sul mingeid teatud sümboleid või asju tal on mingisugune käitumine, aga Sisu on tegelikult ikkagi tekst.
Õpetaja: Ee, Text. Hiddens on mingi. Unustame ära.
Õpetaja: No kuupäev sünnikuupäev. Noh, ma saaks teha seda ka, just, aga ma Just näitasin, onju? Input. Type on date. Ja
Õpetaja: see kast järsku muutus selliseks?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis see veel on? Aga see lekt on juba niukene Põnevam asi, mida teha
Õpetaja: teeme? Mingi laibli ka. Paneme siia mingi h Neli. Mm, vali linn.
Õpetaja: Oli Linn.
Õpetaja: Võibolla mingi ee üks väike, extra Break, et ta natukene alla poole Valilinn
Õpetaja: eesmärk on teha nüüd Selectbox E. Teate küll, ritmenüü
Õpetaja: Tuleme siia Vaali linna ja seal seal peaksid olema Niuksed valikud nagu linn Tallinn Tartu viljandi Ee. Sel
Õpetaja: millise siit võiks valida ja miks
Õpetaja: Select Mix plussiga, mis See, pluss on erinev, on?
Õpetaja: Ta on mitmetasandiline, mitmekihiline.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd see name ja Id. Hetkel kustutame ära Kama
Õpetaja: nüüd. Siin on, et kõik selekti valikud asuvad ee Siin keskel neid saab? Tulla. Mitu
Õpetaja: Nii, ee. Meil on siin öeldud, et. Ee. Las esimene valik oleks Ee, niisugune Kirjastiilis. Kriips linn, Kristlik Kriips,
Õpetaja: Vaatame.
Õpetaja: Oi, aga ma kirjutasin väljusse. Sorry, ee, tahtsin siia. Ee, see on kahe tagiga.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see, et see lekboks on, ee, Selline asi, et tal on nähtav osa, Mis on siin nende tagide vahel
Õpetaja: Tekst?
Õpetaja: Linn on nii,
Õpetaja: Aga teine osa on nähtamatu. Osa selle juurde. Tuleme kohe. Tagasi. Teeme ühe veel. Paneme nüüd siia, siis. Ee, Tallinn
Õpetaja: Publikaad. Teeme veel ühe tartu.
Õpetaja: Tublid Ka Te ei pea nii palju tegema Te võite ka üldiselt vaadata ka üldse viljandi
Õpetaja: viljaniid. Seda ei ole veel.
Õpetaja: On Niukene. Vali linn. Esimene valik on linn Tallinn Tartu viljandi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida on vaja teada? Ripp menüü puhul on see, et ta koosnebki kahest osast iga Option ja see on nüüd nagu, et on mingisugune. Ütleme siis ka enne. Nagu label, mida on näha
Õpetaja: ja on value väljuma midagi, mis on tegelikult taustal, aga seda ei Näe,
Õpetaja: mina ütleks niimoodi, et see lihtsalt linn. Valik on null. Aa, Tallinn on näiteks. Ee. Kolm. Paneme kaks Tartu on kolm viljandi, on üks.
Õpetaja: Ma panen suvalised numbrid. Ma ei tahtnud nendeks kuidagi järjest.
Õpetaja: Kas te näete kuskil neid numbreid ei näe?
Õpetaja: Aga Tegelikult, nad on seal,
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen nüüd siia samma kohta, teen selle ripp menüü peale Parema klõpsu ja vajutan inspekt, et tuleb lahti.
Õpetaja: Ta tuleb elemendi peal lahti. Siinkohal See niimoodi Highlight Id. See on nagu kood. Browser Näitab nagu seda sama asja renderdab. Ütleb, et siin Selecti puhul on midagi, Kui ma teen Selecti lahti,
Õpetaja: siis näete. Siin. Taustal on Tallinna. Vabandust, linna taga on null. Tallinna taga on kaks. Palju taga. On Kolm Selle hiljendi taga on üks Funny
Õpetaja: Meid ei näe, aga seal on väärtused See on tegelik väärtus.
Õpetaja: Tegelik väärtus, Mida sa valid, on Need See on lihtsalt visuaalne pool, mis meid aitab valida Õiget asja, et ma lihtsalt räägin, kui me teeme päris arendust. Meid tegelikult huvitavad hoopis Need asjad enamus ajast
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et need viitavad andmebaasis konkreetselt mingisugusele tabelile ja konkreetsele. Ütleme siis reale.
Õpetaja: Kuskil on Tabel City või Citys Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Seal on näiteks meie süsteemi. Kõik ee konkreetse rippmenüü. Lina
Õpetaja: aja jooksul. Kui tuleb linnu juurde, siis me mitte ei kirjuta kuskil koodi, Nagu praegu. Me teeme käsitsi. Vaid Me oleme andmebaasi. Lisame lihtsalt sinna järjekordsele reale. Ühe uue linna. Need andmed pärinevad seal
Õpetaja: nüüd iga rea Peal on oma Id. Nüüd hakkavad lihtsalt numbreid. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis, kuus. Kunagi ei kordu.
Õpetaja: Kui number viis on meil üks, kaks, Kolm, kui rida kustutada rea ära, kus on kaks
Õpetaja: ja tekitada üks uusi rida, siis järgmine. See. Kaks, ei tule taaskasutusele kunagi
Õpetaja: et kui On üks, kaks, kolm andmebaasist rida. Kaks kustutatakse ära. Ei ole niimoodi et on Üks, kolm, kaks, Näiteks taaskasutust Pole Iga kord, kui mingid Andmed sisaldatakse. Andmebaasi, võetakse järeldloetust. Lihtsalt järgmine number selleks hetkeks. Ja ta on nüüd selle reaga seotud Kuni tema surmani
Õpetaja: Kui see kaob ära, Selline Siis seda numbrit pole.
Õpetaja: Kui žüril on see, siis on nagu. See on relatsioonilise andmebaasi üks põhiprintsiipe
Õpetaja: ja need numbrid väga tihti on niisuguse.
Õpetaja: Sest kui keegi tahab üldse. Kui me tahamegi jõuda lõpuks sinnamaani. Vaata, onju? Me vaatame, mis järgmine asi on, By the way kas, sul patt on, On veel Ei, ole. Et kui ühel hetkel tuleb, siis see hetk. Vaata, kus on nupp. Et näed, et lisa uus inimene, et kui ma tahan valida,
Õpetaja: et see sõnum läheb back end ile, siis mul ei ole vaja seda sõna. Tallinn, Mul ei ole vaja sõna, Tartu. Mul ei ole vaja sõna viljandi.
Õpetaja: Need on ülikama. Need võivad ajas muutuda ka. Mis ei muutu, taga on see
Õpetaja: mis On see number? See huvitab tegelikult meid.
Õpetaja: Me jõuame sinnamaani ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis mõned asjad veel. Ee, näiteks esimene valik siin linn.
Õpetaja: Selle Mõte on see, et ma korra kustutan selle. Või noh, kustutan. Head. Vahet pole, ma kustutan selle headeri ära.
Õpetaja: Praegult oleks arusaadav, mis siin ripp menüüst valida saab.
Õpetaja: Linna On ju, et nagu label It pole,
Õpetaja: aga põhimõtteliselt see annab mulle nagu märku. See on, vot see on juba küll suht tavaline lähenemine, mida tehakse. Sest kui sul on mitu rippenüüd? Kõrvuti, Näiteks mingi filtreerimine
Õpetaja: Booking Ust. Näiteks. Lähed sealt mingeid asju otsima, onju? Kuigi seal on pigem nagu tikpoksid. Aga on ka mõningad kohad. Niimoodi. On Mitu filtrit kõrvuti? Siis sa ei saa teha niimoodi, et Igaühel on label vasakul või paremal. Üleval all on ka variant See lihtsalt läheb mõttetult suureks. Vaata, et saab lihtsalt teha selle triki. Vaata, et see esimene valik
Õpetaja: ongi lihtsalt siis laibli eest. Aga siis tekib probleem,
Õpetaja: et ee. Aga kui mina tulen, Näiteks. Aa, kui ma üldse. Esiteks, esiteks ma üldse midagi ei vali. Oletame, et ma valin Tallinna.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd ma kogemata valin uuesti linna,
Õpetaja: aga see ei ole, see Mida siit on lubatud valida, siis on esimene trikk on see, et me saame öelda sellele Optionile siin siia atribuudi saame öelda, disabled
Õpetaja: see tähendab seda, et see linn ei ole võimalik kuidagi valida,
Õpetaja: et kui ma ta nüüd refresh Ib, iga kord, kui me muudatuse teeme, hetkel ta. Nagu. Kui me tuleme, maandume lehele, teen Refresh on Tallinn ees.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et linna ei ole võimalik valida, on võimalik neid valida
Õpetaja: aga Kui ma ikkagi tahan, vaata, et nagu alguses ta vähemalt oleks nagu vihjena. Siis, Nagu et mida? Siit valida saab,
Õpetaja: siis ma saan panna siia juurde sõna Selected.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on niimoodi, et ta on valitud
Õpetaja: ja tead sa, ta loomulikult peab midagi muud valima,
Õpetaja: kui Aa linn On ju see hetk? Kui me vajutaks nuppu et Lisa uus klient siis me peaksime kontrollima, et see välju hetkel selles ei oleks null,
Õpetaja: Sellepärast null ei ole lubatud. On lubatud ükstaspuha nendest. Mingi on ju Siis on niimoodi, et kasutaja saab valida ühe linna, aga ta ei saa enam
Õpetaja: tagasi valida, et. Noh, see element ongi. Suht niimoodi disainitud
Õpetaja: juba eose ette. Vaata, et sa saad midagi niukest teha,
Õpetaja: Me ei saa enam tagasi minna. No Refresh. Iga saaks. Aga Siis läheks kõik mundamend nagu niiöelda minema.
Õpetaja: On siin kohas küsimusi.
Õpetaja: Ee, no näiteks, kui Ma tahan, et vaikimisi oleks Tartu mingil põhjusel kogu aeg valitud, et, noh, mingi Tartu inimestele suunatud lehekülg
Õpetaja: siis kindlasti on vihje. Vaata, niukest Varianti pole. Nagu sa mõtled, et lihtsalt tekst. Vaata, midagi mis kuvab. Nagu selle ee rippmenüü asemel. Vaata senikaua, kuni vajutad. Lihtsalt see esimene Valik kindl nagu seda teebki. Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: Tartu on valitud. Kui maandud lehele ja linna ei saa valida, onju
Õpetaja: ee, et seal see oleks Nagu atribuuti. Tal ei ole väga hea küsimus.
Õpetaja: Lähme edasi. Ja Nüüd paneme siia Break I paneme jälle kaks korda.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen siia Mingi H. Neli tutvustus
Õpetaja: Ja mõte on nüüd nagu see, et, ee, mis on selle asja puhul see, et kõik on ühel, real, saate mõtest aru.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ei. Ma ei saa entrit vajutada. Ta ei lähe alla.
Õpetaja: Enter ei tee midagi. Aga kui sul on nagu mingi siukene Niuke pikem tekst. Vaata siis, sa. Vot see. Vot Seda ma vihkan ma. Mind ajab närvi. Ma lähen hulluks
Õpetaja: Ee. Kui on eriti, on Need kuradi need Microsofti. Vaata, inimesed teevad nad nii labaselt. Ole hea, pane siia. Mingi tagasiside. Ee, mis sa nagu arvad ja kirjuta meile siin mingi pikk kiri. Aitäh, Oleme tänulikud ja blabla. Ja sa vaatad, et nad on kasutanud sellist kuradi input Box I,
Õpetaja: kui ma kirjutan pika kirja. Ma tahaks lõpus võibolla üle vaadata, et. Noh, kas mingi taipasid on või on mu kõik mõtted seal esindatud, Kuidas ma siis seda saan teha.
Õpetaja: Ooot, lähen edasi oot. Oot, nüüd lähen tagasi
Õpetaja: Ja ma ei tea, Ma ei tea, ma olen näinud netis niukseid asju, Ma olen vormides näinud Asju Ma iga kord mõtlen. Tule taevas appi, Nagu kes selle disainis, Sest et
Õpetaja: see ei ole kasutajasõbralik, on läinud veel. Ei, ei, see võib olla. Ja kõik ülejäänud on nagu. Et kui teil on midagi head meie kohta öelda, siis
Õpetaja: palun väga saate Teksteerija
Õpetaja: Saate teksteeria. Seda tasub võtta, Kui nüüd järgi teha seda ka. Vaata, ee. Teksteeria tasub võtta seda templit. Siin on mõttetult palju mudru, Mis meid ei huvita. Aga see kols ja Rosa, Mis meid huvitab, et Name I saadame pensionile,
Õpetaja: on siis ee, kolmkümmend veergu. Noh, ka Enne nagu tähemärki või nii mitu rida kümme noh. See, on nüüd see koht vaata. Kiitke, meid ja. Siin on pretensioonid on, ju
Õpetaja: ja, Siis seda saabki täpselt niimoodi teha. Et Noh, kui ma panen sinna näiteks viis raud, siis ta on nagu poole lühem. Ma panen siia lõppu. Võibolla paar Breuki, Sest et ta on nii all, nagu et ta ei paista kuidagi praegult välja teile, et saate aru, see on Kast, onju? Ja seda kasti saab niikuinii ise lo lohistada. Ka
Õpetaja: see on Html I. Nagu sisse pandud. Ilmselt saab seda lukku ka panna. Kui tahaks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin on küll võimalik. Näiteks Place Holder.
Õpetaja: See ei ole see jälle toetab, Seda et. Ee, ee, kiitvad sõnad.
Õpetaja: Aa, see on tutvustus. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee. Olen usaldusväärne uus klient,
Õpetaja: et saad panna nagu mingi niukest asja. Nagu et ma ei tea, mida sa kaina, nagu ootad. Jällegi, see ei ole tekst. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd kui sa tahaksid siia teksti panna. Aa, lähme korra Input Boxide juurde tagasi see Eesnimi.
Õpetaja: Ee, asi, mis tuleb pärast hiljem mängu.
Õpetaja: Atribuut. Type Atribuut. Id Attribute Placeholder. Eesnimi on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga mis siis, kui ma tahan, et Siin olekski mingi tekst. Nagu Kohe olemas. Mitte vaid päriselt tekst.
Õpetaja: Siis on Niukene atribuut, mis on enamus ee, kirja kirjutatavatel elementidel on olemas on Value, Ma panen Aa.
Õpetaja: Siis. Siin on päriselt juba tekst. Eelnevalt sees. Aa,
Õpetaja: jätke meelde sellel input. Box Il on Niukene atribuut nagu value
Õpetaja: Ja see defineerib seda ära. Mis siin tegelikult sees on?
Õpetaja: See praegult. Meid ei huvitagi. Meid huvitab see hiljem Natukene
Õpetaja: Siia saaks ka Tutvustuse saaks ka teha. Vaata aga, tutvusta kahtepidi. Vaata, sest tal on. Ta on kahe täägiga
Õpetaja: teksteeria et, sa saad siia panna aa Peaks, olema see, et seal on. Ju on
Õpetaja: Aga ma. Ma peast ei tea. Kas ta siis toetab. Ka Väljud?
Õpetaja: Ee, võib proovida.
Õpetaja: Palju Näed, Ta juba ei tahtnud seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ei ole,
Õpetaja: et näiteks kahe tag I puhul ei ole. Ehk siis ma eeldan, et see välju on Pigem nagu tekstiline. Noh, saab ka number, olla Mis iganes kuupäev, et see pigem siis on ühe tagiga elemendid ikka. Kui on kahe tag, Iga Siis läheb vanaviisi. Vot igal pool. Kus meil on kaks tag I label, Label
Õpetaja: Ee, H, üks Dd. Kõik on kahe tag, iga Onju Kahe tag iga.
Õpetaja: Kui tahad mingit teksti panna, siis palun väga saad panna mingi hetk teksti ette.
Õpetaja: No, reaalne vajadus võibki olla, et Sa soovidki panna sinna mingit teksti sisse, nagu. Ja siis inimene peaks justkui midagi ise edasi kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Nii Kustutame need ära. Tutvustused on olemas, Ee, input radio.
Õpetaja: Teeme kõigepealt Lablay label foori. Jätame esiteks Aa, tühjaks.
Õpetaja: Kirjutame. Mees.
Õpetaja: Teisel vähem naine algus on siis umbes, kus ta siin all on tasu peale panna.
Õpetaja: Mingeid Break e siia lõppu. Nagu et see on hästi lehe alla. Vaata, meil on leht nii pikaks läinud juba.
Õpetaja: Aa, siin on kaks labelit. Mees. Naine.
Õpetaja: Paneme korra siia. Preigi ka vahele.
Õpetaja: Väike mees, naine.
Õpetaja: Ee, võib ka panna siia mingi headeri. Noh, sugu vä.
Õpetaja: Ja minu mõte nüüd on see. Vaata, et ee, võiks siia panna nagu ette, et sa pead valima üks või teine.
Õpetaja: Siis. Ee, oota. Kas me soovime seda tikki siia järgi või jätta? Kuidas teile tunduks parem? Kas ta on siin vasakul? See on see Need kastikesed. Ma pigem paneks siia ette Ma tuleksin siia Labely ette
Õpetaja: ja paneksin siia. Aa, ee input imp
Õpetaja: ja üks R täht ka juurde. Radio. Ma soovin sellist maili, mis on input radio. Lihtsalt taipan radio. Siis Ei, pea käsitsi kirjutama,
Õpetaja: impr.
Õpetaja: Ja siis see tab
Õpetaja: ee, Võibolla selle koera jalale. Ee, siin on ainult taipar. Radio. Ee, Id võiks ära kustutada. Neimi jätame esialgu alles. Tegelikult kustutame neimi ka, ära, Sest Ta võib olla Demo mõttes ei tööta mul siis päris nii, nagu ma tahaks. Sa oled lihtsalt input Radio
Õpetaja: tuleb. Ee, Julla ette tuleb.
Õpetaja: No siis aa. Selle võib copida
Õpetaja: panna ka ette siia, et et meil on sugu input. Radio Label Break
Õpetaja: Input Radio label naine, et tuleks niuke disain. Olete tuttav niukse disainiga.
Õpetaja: Kuskil ikka on. Pead valima niimoodi üks või teine.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: nüüd, kuidas Radio Baton töötab versus Checkbox. No ma teen ka ruttu alla. Korra näidiseks siia ühe checkboxi. See on korra vaatamise koht. Checkbox?
Õpetaja: Mis? On, Mis on nende vahe,
Õpetaja: Mis on, ee, Nende vahe ja nende vahe Ühest saad ainult ühe valida. Teisest saad mitu, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga kui me praegult hakkaks tegema seda Vajutad, Mees
Õpetaja: vaid on naine. Siis mis jama on vanem?
Õpetaja: Saad mõlemat valida. Neil ei ole nagu selles mõttes mul siin üle lehe olla, neid input. Ee, reidioid mingeid tuhandeid ka. Kui oleks niisugune lehekülg.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mis reeglit see oleks, Niuke, aga kui oleks, meil on vaja nagu mingisugust ühist osa. Vaata, kuidas need kaks asja omavahel siduda.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me selliselt vaatasime Id D, mis viitab konkreetselt ühele ainsale elemendile, siis nüüd siin sellises kohas. Meil on esimest korda kus? Nagu name on asjakohane asi selle input I juurde paneme name I
Õpetaja: ja Siin on jälle vaja nüüd ühte Nagu mingisugust sõna. Vaata, mis siis kuidagi iseloomustaks. Seda on vaja nagu mõlemas teha. Mõlemas on vaja panna Atribuut juurde ja neile see sisu peaks olema täpselt üks ja see sama, mis seob nad omavahel ära, et nad on mõeldud nagu koos olema.
Õpetaja: No mis nime pakute?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me mõtleme, et teema on nagu sugu Gender
Õpetaja: gender on väga okei, Mõnes kohas olen näinud nagu ka, et pannakse lihtsalt seks.
Õpetaja: See on nagu.
Õpetaja: Aga gender oleks niisugune. Natukene neutraalsem.
Õpetaja: Ja vaadake, kui me paneme selle genderi, paneme siia teise
Õpetaja: Ka siis nüüd on niimoodi, et see asi võibolla ükstaspuha siin selles koodi mõttes kuskil üleval, pool allpool Vahet pole nad on nüüd selles Html is Inputid on omavahel seotud,
Õpetaja: et kui ma tulen siia, midagi juhtus, ka Siin vist ei juhtunud. Ma võtan, mees. Naine siis on, Reidio töötab niimoodi, et üks või teine
Õpetaja: saate mõttes aru. See on nagu grupeerimine, Kui ma tõstan näiteks selle sama asja korra siit, Ee, Noh, mina ei tea
Õpetaja: kohe siia algusesse, et mul on. Ma olen mees või ma olen naine,
Õpetaja: aga mõlemad ei saa olla, saate aru? Sellest mõttest. See on nagu. Kuidas ta siis, nagu, tegelikult taustal nagu töötab.
Õpetaja: Nojah, ee, okei, mees, naine.
Õpetaja: Noh, Password, Ma korra näitasin, Taipan Lihtsalt mis ma valisin.
Õpetaja: Aa, sa mõtled sellel siin, onju? Jah, ee, idee järgi. No see on nagu. See Vaata, et vaata, kui ma selle foori ära. Võtan selle.
Õpetaja: Siis ütleb, et. Näe, kui nii ei ole hea. Oi, vanasti ta vingus. Näe Nüüd enesega enam ei Vingu.
Õpetaja: Vau, see on edasi läinud. Vahepeal mul on hea meel, kusjuures, sest et see tegelikult on nonsens, ma kunagi hiljem selgitan, miks
Õpetaja: ee, idee järgi, Kui ma tahaksin seda labelit. Ee, vaata, miks see label jälle. Võibolla kuidagi võib olla abistav Ja kasulik ongi see, et Jah, silma järgi. Me näeme, et need asjad on omavahel seotud.
Õpetaja: Aga seal on näiteks see. Vaata, et kui keegi läheb vaegnägija, vajab oma ee, mingi Screen Reader I asjaga. Läheb selle valiku peale. Noh, ta läheb selle peale,
Õpetaja: et ta siis tegelikult siis Screen Reader saaks tegelikult, vaadata et Milline label on seotud? Ee, selle
Õpetaja: ee, selle konkreetse tippboksiga. Vaata ja ta saaks siis lugeda, näiteks selle väärtuse naine ja mees veel onju,
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, see on alles uus asi. Ma ütlen, et vanasti tegelikult oli kollane joon, alla Kui sa ei ühendanud leeglit ära või abil Mingisuguse konkreetse valikuga. Siis nii öelda, Mille kohta sa leidnud? Ee, aga ma. Sellel on nagu Niukene värk vaata, et ee,
Õpetaja: see Id on Niukene asi mida üldse, mina? Nagu oma Htm is väldiks. Siis kui me vähemalt läheme poe poesse, kus ee, poetehnoloogiasse raamistiku, kus me programmeerime. Ja kus väga paljud asjad Ee tekivad. Dünaamiliselt
Õpetaja: mitte niimoodi valmis kirjutatud kujul, vaid erinevate käitumismudelite abil. Niiöelda rendeldatakse kogu niiöelda leht ega See Apollo Kino lehekülg, mis on üheksa tuhat kilomeetrit.
Õpetaja: See vist oli mingi. See oli üheksakümmend või üheksa tuhat Vida pikka. Vaata, Ega seda inimene Ei ole ju kirjutanud, selge? See kuidagi pannakse kooki.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle raamistiku poolt. Ee, et Id Dega on lihtsalt see It tehniliselt ei tohiks Olla ühes Atm rohkem kui üks kord, et seal võib tekkida see probleem, et sa. Kas sa saad garanteerida, et see päriselt ka nii on?
Õpetaja: Kui meil hakkab dünaamiliselt sisu tekkima, siis võib ühte elementi tulla mitu korda
Õpetaja: ja siis ei saa olla niimoodi, et sul on ühte elementi sama. Mitu korda,
Õpetaja: et ma mõt. Jah, ma küsin teistmoodi siis, et, ee, kui ma teeks praegu valiku, mees, kas ütleme vabastaks väärtuse mees. Ja, aga Aga seda juba tuleks juba programmiliselt.
Õpetaja: See tuleks selles mõttes. Ee. See tuleks programmiliselt. Ja selle jaoks tal tegelikult ei ole vaja. Id.
Õpetaja: Ma pean korra mõtlema, et. Ee, sügaval karukohus Võibolla on. On ju
Õpetaja: ee meelde. Kuidas ma saan kätte väärtuse? Tuleme selle juurde tagasi,
Õpetaja: Tuleme selle juurde tagasi siis, kui me hakkame programist tegema, siis vaatame, kuidas Voes on, et ma praegult ütleksin, et siis kui sa tahaksid. Kui me täna sealt praegu tahaks ikka vanilla javaskrit teha, siis oleks Id D vaja.
Õpetaja: Muud moodi ei saaks. Jah, ei, saaks muud moodi. Selle leibli jaoks otseselt ei ole vajalik, aga see oleks ilus. Ja kena vaata, on ju? Aga Kuidas, me täna, nagu teeme Aa, Niimoodi Üsna mustalt. Aa Mitte mustalt, vaid vanilla. Jaava Teeme vaid homme. Võibolla
Õpetaja: siis seal me muud moodi seda kätte ei saaks,
Õpetaja: Meil oleks Id D vaja. Ee, taotluslikult. Mul on jäetud kolm Id Tsi ja last. Name, et nendega me mängime ja Scriptis, kui me jõuame sinnamaani, Võibolla isegi jõuame. Jah, homme peaks jõudma küll.
Õpetaja: Kuidas pausiga oli? Mis kell me tulime? Kas te jaksate? Veel Viiskümmend?
Õpetaja: Me oleme ainult tund Ja tund. Ja Seitse minutit. Kas teeme veel natukene jaksate? Kuidas tunnete?
Õpetaja: Teeme edasi, Kurat. Ee, Vaatame. Äkki jõuame. Isegi Näed, me ei olegi kaugel. Tegelikult Cc asjadest. Teeme siis need ära. On ju? Mis iganes siin on. Siin palju pole jäänud. Ee, järgmine asi võiks olla siis Ee link, Näiteks kõigepealt checkbox.
Õpetaja: Jah, ee. Noh, teeme Siin kaks Break I, näiteks imp ja C.
Õpetaja: Siit tuleb otsida see checkbox. Välja.
Õpetaja: Jällegi Ega me tegelikult midagi muud siit ei tahagi? Kui ainult see oleks saanud käsitsi ka selle
Õpetaja: suht kiirelt teha. Selle ülejäänud staffi kustutakse ära, Lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee, ei ole vaja. Neid teisi atribuute. Aga lihtsalt jälgige, kuidas kustutate, Onju, et kõik need jutumärgid et Ei, tuleks, näiteks tema
Õpetaja: niimoodi Läheb sündaks katki. Punane annab märku.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, ee, input. Ja nüüd võiks teha niukse, asja, et ee, siin tuleb otsa. Kohe tekst
Õpetaja: Ma Praegu kirjutaks. Lihtsalt. Aa, Okei, Mis tekst? Mis teksti elemente te praegu teate? Mida me oleme siiamaani käsitlenud. Kuhu Saab lihtsalt teksti panna
Õpetaja: Paragrahv Pealkiri header ja üks oli veel teksti.
Õpetaja: Kast on see juba?
Õpetaja: Ma räägin tekstmist on nagu teksti kujul mitte nagu kasutaja poolt sisestatav üks oli veel
Õpetaja: okei. Kui ma tahaksin niimoodi. Ma ütlen, mis see plaan on. Plaan on seda et on checkbox ja siis tuleb tekst, nõustun kõikide tingimustega.
Õpetaja: Ja see tingimus, et saab veel link olema. See on nagu pikk plaan. Ehk Ma tahaksin, et siia visuaalis võiks tulla niimoodi, et tuleb siia alla checkbox,
Õpetaja: mida saab tšekkida ja siia tuleb tekst Nõustun kõikide tingimustega. Lihtsalt Kuidas me seda Brad saaks teha? No Üks Variant oleks panna lihtsalt tekst
Õpetaja: nõustu. Noh, vaatan, kas ta tuleb siia. Tuleb siia otsa, aga nii ei ole ilus sellepärast, et see tekst ei asu ühegi elemendi sees.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks mingit Cs I panna mingit disaini teha. Siis ma ei saa seda kuidagi teha. Ma ei saa viidata kuidagi sellele sõnana Nõustan,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen Paragrahv.
Õpetaja: Paragrahvil on üks omadus.
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan nõustun, blabla bla blabla, mis pärast halvasti on,
Õpetaja: pole Samal real. Sellepärast paragrahv seda täpselt teebki. Misiganes on üleval, Ta lööb sellest enne sammu. Võrra Allapoole on seal. Tekst on seal pilt, Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Siin on praegu lihtsalt boks, on ju? See ei sobi meile.
Õpetaja: Noh, ei sobiks ka Tegelikult mingi A üks onju, siis on üldse Jama lugu on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga on üks asi veel, mis on nagu hästi neutraalne, mis ei tee mingit spacing Ut ega mitte midagi, aga On Teksti on millegi sees. Vähemalt,
Õpetaja: et see tekst jääb millegi sisse.
Õpetaja: Vihjaks. Ütlen, et vaatasime ka seda Spänn. Spän on. Ulatused on neutraalne, Ta ei tekita. Vot mäletate, on ju meil siin? Spänn On meil ju siin kuskil sees. Kas ta tekitas mingit vahe või midagi? Ei tekitand. Seega spänn on nagu ideaalne asi.
Õpetaja: Kirjuta siia seas bän päev ja siis kirjutada. Nõustun kõigi tingimustega.
Õpetaja: Noh, pole mingi kolm punkti, mida Iganes, onju.
Õpetaja: Vaatan, mis tuli ka. Ma nõustun kõigi tingimustega. Ja vaadake sees. See nagu reavahetus ei ole nagu koodis, nagu selles mõttes osa Html ist
Õpetaja: ei ole rea, et checkbox on ühel real just on. Kõigi tingimustega. On ju teisel Real Koodi mõttes,
Õpetaja: aga mitte nagu lõpptulemuse mõttes sellepärast, et need kõik need tühikud Muidu võiks niimoodi ka olla, ju?
Õpetaja: Kas mul on nüüd nagu checkbox ja siis viis kilomeetrit tühjust Ja siis tuleb tingimustega. Ei ole
Õpetaja: me. See ei ole osa koodist. Vaata, see kõik niiöelda ruumi kokkuhoiu mõttes kui isegi jätad niukse asja, Siis lõpptulemuses on ta ikkagi ka enda Nagu
Õpetaja: ära söödud enamvähem.
Õpetaja: Nii, see on selle. Vaatan meile enda poolt niiöelda juba
Õpetaja: okei, nõustun kõigi tingimustega. Noh, seda saab siin checkida.
Õpetaja: Ee, saaks see siis olla nagu eeldus, et kui vajutad lõpuks et lisa, uus klient, või mis iganes, Siis nagu ennem nagu edasi, ei saa, öeldakse, et. Kuule, et No teate. Ikka, öeldakse, et nõustage tingimustega. Kavalalt peidetakse sinna alla ka järgmine Tickbox. Ära või ettevaata, Onju, et soovin saada meie uudise kirju, ja mida iganes. Nõustun, sellega et annan oma andmed nagu
Õpetaja: Forever kuhugi kasutusse, See on see vabatahtlik,
Õpetaja: aga tavaliselt ikkagi tikitakse mõlemad, eksole?
Õpetaja: Ma nõustun kõigi tingimustega Nüüd järgmine asi võiks olla see, et. Ee, me tekitame Lingi Esialgu me teeme lingi, mis läheb kuhugi välisesse kohta.
Õpetaja: Nõustun kõigi tingimustega. Teeme siia alla. Lihtsalt, Ee. Siis ee, lingi. Nüüd Link ei Ole link.
Õpetaja: Link on Ee, element a f.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen korra. Kas Ee saab nii ka A ja
Õpetaja: ta pakub seda malli kuskil siin. All. Vaata, Aa, link. Näete seda?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis ta on. Seda saab ise ka kirjutada. See ei ole midagi keerulist. Lihtsalt panna Korra A, Tab.
Õpetaja: Aa, näed nüüd. Ta tegi kuidagi väga kiirelt teed Siis Ta teeb niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on kahe osaline Niiöelda see on kahe niiöelda Kahe tag. Iga element siin on tekst.
Õpetaja: Panen siia sõna tingimustega tingimustega. Ta Praegu veits dubleerib, Aga mõttest saate aru, on link.
Õpetaja: See on See teksti osa praegu. Klikid Ega ta midagi muud Ei, tee? Kui tegelikult ma ei tea, vist. Ta teeb siis taustal kuidagi mingil põhjusel Refresh I vist. Või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Aga mõte on nagu loomulikult viia. Nagu need asjad Niimoodi kokku. Saate aru,
Õpetaja: et ta nõu nõustun kõigi Tingimustega.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see referents siia käib siis mingi link,
Õpetaja: kui see on väline link või? Noh, mingi meie enda mingi süsteemi link, aga ta on sellegipoolest väline link Mitte mingi osa meie projektist siin. Ee, siis näiteks ma võin Otsida. Praegult. Ee, Lhv. Lhv. Tingimused Näiteks
Õpetaja: Ee Lhv Tingimused ja hinnakiri. Tulen, võtan lihtsalt selle lingi
Õpetaja: nagu Apolloga. Aga mul Lhv ga mingit diili ei ole, ei saanud sellepärast tasuta maja laenu või midagi, et,
Õpetaja: ee, korra mainin neid siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, siia referentsi saabki panna siis lingi, et kui sa klikid selle peale, siis mis saama Hakkab,
Õpetaja: et kui sa nüüd tuled tagasi oma vaatele, Kui sa klikid sellele sõna tingimustega,
Õpetaja: siis selles samas leh sellel samal lehel minnakse Ee Sellele lingile, mis me panime. No Packiga saab tagasi.
Õpetaja: Mõte, on selge?
Õpetaja: Nii?
Õpetaja: No nüüd saaks siis teha niimoodi, et Ee, nõustun kõigi tingimustega, et selle teksti võtaksid. Ee, sellest päris tekstist ära, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja jääks siis kombinatsioonina kokku.
Õpetaja: Nõust vajutades Jah, ee, see on mingi open Target Target tarbet
Õpetaja: blank. I think nüüd ka. Atribuut tuleb juurde panna.
Õpetaja: Ma proovin üle. Vaata, kas see on nii. Kõigepealt
Õpetaja: siis teeb uue tab I lahti.
Õpetaja: Ja see on selles mõttes kasulik. Ee, see on ka nagu selline asi, mida tegelikult tuleb väga läbi mõelda. Mina teen ühte keskkonda, mis ajab mind lihtsalt hulluks. Aga õnneks enam ma ei külasta seda, Kuna Euroopa direktiivid ee muutusid. Meil ei olnud direktiivid lihtsalt nende enda Euroopa komisjoni. Mingisugused seadused ja asjad muutusid. Seal ei olnudki vaja millegagi nõustuda
Õpetaja: Tegelikult oli vaja ratifitseerida, kuidagi riikidel ma ei teagi see sündis.
Õpetaja: Jah, see on, ee. Selles mõttes peab olema hästi läbimõeldud asi. Vaata, mina ütlen kasutajana. Mind ajab närvi, kui pekstakse järjest mulle uusi taba lahti.
Õpetaja: Ebavajalikud, kes oskab öelda vähe selle ostukeskkonna, kus ta on märganud, et see täpselt nii on.
Õpetaja: Romaan I know Te kõik shopate seal.
Õpetaja: No muidugi, Searchid.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas Search I peale viskab uue Searchiga Veel on viisakas Paljutad ühe asja lahti. Ta teeb selle Kohe uues Tab is lahti.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd sealt midagi ei julgen Searchida või vajutada. Ta teeb uued Täb I lahti, et nagu on Mul Kümme tab i Lahti vaata.
Õpetaja: Aa, Ma, ei tea mis, nad on niimoodi valinud mind. Isiklikult Tuleb see viha sest, et, ma ei saa. Ma tahaks lihtsalt nagu minna. Vaata, ma tahaks ise kontrollida. Ma oskan ise ka nupule parema klõpsu peale panna.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on kreisi,
Õpetaja: Ma olen niikuinii. See. Kahjuks see inimene, kellel chrom Is on. Kakskümmend tuhat. Tab I korraga lahti.
Õpetaja: Te olete ka sihukesed vä
Õpetaja: Ee, ma Ei tea, kui te nägite, siis ee. Mina, nagu panin endal Chromis selle küljemenüü.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul Tegelikult üldse meeldib ka need Windows is külje menüü Sellepärast, et niimoodi näeb nagu normaalsemalt. Ja vaata, kui palju neid saab ritta panna. Niimoodi, et näed. Vot muidugi lähevad niisuguseks, nagu
Õpetaja: nad Lähevad ainult selleks ristiks ära. Lõpuks ei saa midagi aru on ju Ja siis on nagu. Mis asja ma pean hakkama nüüd selle pärast sulgema. Mingit
Õpetaja: tegelikult. See võtab arvuti jõudust ka maha ja kõike seda. Vaata, et ee, veis tuleb neid ikka panna. Aga. No lõpuks teed see. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: pane kõik paremale kinni või vasakule. Teate küll, kuidas saab seda auto täitmist ee kuidagi parandada, Sest kui ma panen järgmise Reale sisestama, siis ta paneb mulle ainult esimese osa. Proovi rääkida, kuhu ma vajutan. Mida ma tean? Kuidas ma reprodutseerin seda, mis sa räägid,
Õpetaja: Aa, kui ma tahan spamfunktsiooni valida, siis ta ei paku, kui ma hakkan sisestama spa ja siis ta pakub mulle ainult esi esimest osa sellest, et ei paku mulle nagu täisfunktsiooni.
Õpetaja: Kirjutad Spani
Õpetaja: ja siis ta annab mulle ainult pool, sellest Okei, või juhul kui ta annab pool sellest, siis üks väikene trikk. Ee, ma proovin selle, et kui ma niimoodi annab, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, niimoodi. Kui sa vajutad, Ee, siis ta ei Tee seda, aga. Control Shift võiks. Aidata
Õpetaja: Aa, seda Selle asja nimi on. Näete, vaata, mul on siin presentation assistant ka peal selle asja nimi on Co Varsidel. Üks eriti jaavaste lemmiknopud. Mingi asja automaat lõpu tegemine, et kui on Niukene olukord Control Shift Enter
Õpetaja: teeb ülejäänud, poole ära.
Õpetaja: See tuleb. Ee. Kui me hakkame päris seda poe asja tegema. Ja jaavas, eriti ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on väga, väga mõnus. Ee, nuppude Kombinatsioon, mis aitab tööd palju kiiremini teha.
Õpetaja: Nii ee, praegu. Nüüd siis saime selle tehtud, et nõustun kõigi tingimustega. Avab niimoodi kenasti uues staab is lahti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. See oli External link,
Õpetaja: Aga minul on nüüd üks. Ee Üks mõte. Mis tegelt nüüd on hästi tähtis, Selles mõttes, lihtsalt Nagu kuulata ja meelde jätta. Ja kui ma tulen ringiga paari päeva juures selle teema juurde. Tagasi. Ee, meil on praegult üks indeks Atm Leht vastutajale.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta on tegelikult selle frontend. Kaustas on nii? Selle all ta on. Teeme juurde ühe faili. Tuleme selle frontend I peale, Paneme parem klõps
Õpetaja: New
Õpetaja: Siit. Valime, et veitsa, et ta paneks selle lõpu juba ise ära. Et ütleme, et tahan uut Html failida ja Valite selle valiku.
Õpetaja: Parem klõps. Frontend I peale New
Õpetaja: Mitte lihtsalt fail, vaid Html. Fail tõstab kerge põhja ära. Ee, ta küsib nüüd ee Faili nimi. Ee, paneme näiteks tingimused.
Õpetaja: Mentorid titli. Noh, selle title Võibolla ad I võib panna. Pane ee, panemegi tingimused.
Õpetaja: Nii, No nüüd ma Panen siia. Ma ei tea, kas loore Ipsome on kasutaja lubatud. Või Loore
Õpetaja: on ikka kuidagi. Ee, vahet pole. Okei Paragrahv.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, tal ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ahah. Teate, olete näinud mingit veebilehti? Kus see rõhk on? Pandud disainile kõigele? Ee, sisu poolest on lihtsalt mingisugune mõttetu ladina keelne Tekst, mis tavaliselt hakkab, Olete näinud? Seda Ei ole,
Õpetaja: see on. See on lihtsalt põhimõtteliselt nagu suvaline tekstitäide. Lihtsalt siit sa intellises ka vä vältida.
Õpetaja: Aga Quick Fox
Õpetaja: Ainult noorem on. Vaata,
Õpetaja: jah, ee. Mõte on. Nagu. Teeme selle asja nagu lõpuni, Siis see, nagu selgub Vaata, et Te võite ka lihtsalt teha siia, mis ma tegin. Ma tegin paragrahvi
Õpetaja: B.
Õpetaja: Tegin selle paragrahvi täägi valmis ja kirjutasin lorem ma. Ütlesin kohe Täby.
Õpetaja: Ja ta lihtsalt teeb mingisuguse teksti. Kui ma kirjutan siia. Näiteks Ee, paragrahv. Seda ei pea järgi tegema. Lorem viiskümmend, siis ta paneb seda sama teksti. Lihtsalt viiskümmend korda.
Õpetaja: See selgub, miks. Vaata, nagu hiljem.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Mis me tahame teha, on see, et me läheme, peaasi et Mingit sisu on? Kas kui paar sõna sinna bla blabla kirjutada? Vahet pole, mõte. Nüüd on see, et meil on nüüd kaks Html I,
Õpetaja: Kui mina panen siia Kaldkriips, ja tingimused,
Õpetaja: tingimused. Äkki ma pean Atml ka Panema. Juurde.
Õpetaja: Läks valesti, Vä,
Õpetaja: Tinggi siia. Kirjutasin valesti. Vä. Ahah, ongi tiimusad.
Õpetaja: Näita seda teksti. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: see on nagu mõte on see, et siis on nagu Need on meie tingimused, aga see on lihtsalt kohatäide. Vaata, ee, vot korraks see ka.
Õpetaja: Ee enda. See on ladina keeles. See on mingi bullshit. Nagunii
Õpetaja: ladina keele. Ammoonium, bla blabla, mis Pärinebla, mis ta kirjutatakse. Ee,
Õpetaja: ei tähenda ladina keeles midagi sisuliselt. See on tahtlikult lahti öeldud, okei? Isegi ladina keeles ei tähenda see mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: aga ütleme niimoodi. Kui te näiteks vaatate kuskil mingeid Ee Wordpress I malle ja asju vaata ja seal on nagu mingid, noh, et Sul on nagu mingid teksti, paragrahvid ja asjad ja seda tahetakse välja teha. Keegi ei viitsi seda sisu toota, Siis see see on lihtsalt Tekstiline kohatäida. See klassikaline
Õpetaja: tahaks. See peab ikka mingi miiniga olema. Nagu.
Õpetaja: Nii Aga mina lähen korra tagasi nüüd siia. Meie panka kustutan selle Siit ära vaata nüüd. Mõte ongi see, et. Ee. Kas vastab tõele, et meil on siin projektis nüüd rohkem kui üks Html fail,
Õpetaja: on ju nii, okei. Jätame selle meelde
Õpetaja: nüüd. Aa, meie läheme tagasi selle lingi juurde, kus meil oli see Arf
Õpetaja: ja kuna ta asub Aa, Ta ei asu. Meil public taustal. Ma natuke pean mõtlema. Aa, tema jaoks praegult.
Õpetaja: Kui ma hakkaks siia kirjutama kaldkriips või tühik, vaata siis Ta pakub kaarti. Tingi. Aa pakub isegi tingimused. Kas ta on selle sama all?
Õpetaja: Ma võin korra valida selle tingimuse. Ma korra kõigepealt proovin, Aga minu sisetunne ütleb, et kui ma vajutan siia tingimused, aga ikkagi tuleb lahti
Õpetaja: Ee, siis niimoodi on võimalik, nagu ära linkida mingit teist lehte, mis on meie rakenduses?
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru, et see ei ole enam see Lhv. Ee, niiöelda aadress vaid see on meie enda lehekülg. No siis mängult olekski niimoodi, et. Ee, mina olen siin. Nõustun kõigi tingimustega. Tahan vaadata, mis need tingimused on. Ja siis siin on mingid tingimused
Õpetaja: midagi taolist
Õpetaja: Mis on see, mida ma palun teil praegu meelde jätta, on lihtsalt väga distinktiv. Seda, et meil. On Aa. Kui me Läheme kaldkriips tingimused, siis meil avatakse see Html fail, mis on siin. Ee, niiöelda eraldi,
Õpetaja: et meil on rohkem kui üks vaataml,
Õpetaja: Sest ma juba ütlen. Aina. Ütle, et ta ära ütlen. Ikka,
Õpetaja: siis ma ütlen, et edaspidi, kui me hakkame voega toimetama, meil on ainult üks Html Fail.
Õpetaja: See sama indeks. Aat on veel.
Õpetaja: Ei ole neid. Mitu. Jõuame selle juurde Siis kui on aeg,
Õpetaja: aga siis on teil hea mäletada,
Õpetaja: Vot see on küll. Neliteist. Viisteist ongi täpselt poolteist tundi. Ma arvan, et. Ee. Vaata korra, linked.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, jätame nüüd ülejäänud kolm ikkagi Peale pausi teeme hästi väikse breigi. Mina teen samal ajal
Õpetaja: Ee. Ma panen mingi Work in progress. Kaks mis iganes, Comitee Bush.
Õpetaja: Teeme siis Viisteist pinsa pausi, kes tahab tulla järgi. Mis need sammud? Olid? Öelge mulle, kui tahate järgi tulla,
Õpetaja: kui midagi seal on, onju ja siis Ee, Valida lihtsalt sealt õpetaja.
Õpetaja: Siis sa teed selle asemel, et sa teed selle ee, vasakalt.
Õpetaja: Mm, jah.
Õpetaja: Ta näitab kõiki neid muudatusi, mis Sulle on onju, et kõik vaatad siia ülemisele, et sa mõlemad niiöelda
Õpetaja: kirjuta Siia, lihtsalt, ee, käin pooleli tagasi.
Õpetaja: Pole isegi vahel, kuhu see Keelseks
Õpetaja: jäi pooleli. Ja nüüd sa vajutad. Ee,
Õpetaja: aa, see üks teine asi. Ee, sul on. Ee, Pane lihtsalt siia. Pane oma esimene. See ei lähe kuhugi niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Ei, ma tegelikult ka. Mida iganes olla.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda ma ei teeks. Tegelikult ta ei vasta standardile Ätt on puudu. Ü, tähed asjad. Vaata, Pane see.
Õpetaja: Aa, sa kaid oma perekonna nimesid.
Õpetaja: Pane kirja Kerli punkt. E, E. Kas seal ei ole vahet? Paneme lugu.
Õpetaja: Ma panen Kerli null, null, kaks, mingi üks. Keemaja läks kaduma. Ja teine ka. Okei,
Õpetaja: okei, parem ikka. Ma olen näinud et mingi, Seksikiisu viisteist ja inimesed ikka ei lase lahti mu ema eest. Ee,
Õpetaja: nüüd on niimoodi. Vaata, see on aru. Vaata, Kerli V, kaks vaata, Ongi täpselt nii, nagu sul see töö poolele jäid.
Õpetaja: Nüüd sina saad ikka nüüd teha selle järgmise sammu, mis on, Vaatad peegeldus sellise? Ära Tege ära
Õpetaja: nende otsid. Ee, õpetaja.
Õpetaja: Minu bränz.
Õpetaja: Sul on see alati olemas. Seal tee see korra Ära võtta. Sa saad pärast vaadata
Õpetaja: e Kaks checkout I ka, onju?
Õpetaja: Näed, sul läheb see vee kolme siia, kui sa liigud selle niiöelda noorse peale
Õpetaja: V, üks ja V kaks ka olemas. Aga v kahe ajal on ka siis need muudatused. Nii nagu pooleli jäi. Täpselt see sees. Iga kell saab teha sellele Checkout I ja vaadata seda iga kell saab nüüd tulla sellele Iga kell saab sellele tulla, et kõik need on nagu olemas. Checkout Näiteks
Õpetaja: Tehke Kolm läks kahes. Nüüd on jälle see seis.
Õpetaja: Aga ma tahan mõlemat pilti nagu ette endale saada, et võrrelda.
Õpetaja: Aga ma näitan seda siis, Kui klassis oleme. Tagasi Aa, sa saad võrrelda File, eksju? Aa, selle valiku, tõesti
Õpetaja: et. Noh, printsiibis vaataks, et vähemalt töötab, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, minu Siis töötab jah? Ee, Siin on mingisugune eripära. Midagi on kraamivõrra teistmoodi. See Ultimate ei tööta
Õpetaja: meeles. Ei, ole andrus. Ma annan sulle võtme, Sa saad siis ära legada ja teha endale.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga kui soovib. Täna kannatad veel ära. Vaata
Õpetaja: Panid mingi nime, Valisid need failid, on ju. Ee, kersti Vee kaks. Ee. Nüüd Sul on niimoodi. Et sul on pra projekti puhul ja tegelt üleüldseid selle kinti puhul, nagu ära New Yorku teed, siis ta tahab teada, et nagu, kes sa nagu oled. Sul on nagu ühe korra vaja. Nagu öelda,
Õpetaja: ja minu eemal On see eemal? Ei lähe kuskile. Selles mõttes ei pea midagi kartma.
Õpetaja: Nii, pane see.
Õpetaja: Jah.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, mhmh
Õpetaja: nii. Nüüd ta teeb niimoodi, et Vaata need ka siit ära. Sest ta on nüüd salvestatud siia Harusse. Nüüd sa teed ikkagi sellepärast, et sa pead, ee, enne kui sa Võtad mult uue haru?
Õpetaja: Tere, Risto. Rääkida, eks?
Õpetaja: Tehtud õpilane või topilane või topikoppilane?
Õpetaja: Nii, kõik ma lihtsalt tahtsin salvestada. Jah, siis on tehtud
Õpetaja: Ja kui sul näiteks oleks kodus arvuti. Vaata, sa saaksid. Kui sa ära, siis ta on pilves ka. Vaata, see automaatselt ei toime. Hakka seda tasuks ära teha. Ma pean ka seda vaatama.
Õpetaja: Ja see on nagu see. Vaata, et vaata variant on niimoodi, et kas ta salvestab ära. Nagu et sa oled ainult selle projekti vaates või vahel pole mis iganes, aga teed mõne muu projekti lahti, et on sama, põhimõtteliselt Üks on nagu globaalne. Teine taask on globaalne. Vaata
Õpetaja: aga, sa näedki ainult. Seda, mida sina teed. Mis on sinu haru,
Õpetaja: aga see tähendab Minu arvuti ja see. See ei ole veel mitte keegi. Nagu selles mõttes, et ütleme, kui mina panen praegu kaheksakümmend kaheksa võib. Sina.
Õpetaja: Jah, See on nagu server, mis on, nagu see sama ongi. Vaata serveri aadress praegu.
Õpetaja: Vaata, kui muidu on. Vaata, näiteks Www punkt Lhv punkt E. E, siis tegelikult taustal on veel mingisugused numbrid. Mingi üks ajaks. Üks punkt, üks aadress. Praegult. Sellisel asjal ei olegi mingisugust muud aadressi, Kui Vaata, kohalik nagu võõrustaja. Ja see server, nagu jookseb ainult sinu arus
Õpetaja: ja samamoodi on tegelikult selle ee, andmebaasid, mis meil on seal Samamoodi on ainult minu arvat nii?
Õpetaja: Kui ma ise kirjutan, siis
Õpetaja: sul. Sul on see probleem, et kuskil on sul see Htmell on ise katki. Vaata läinud.
Õpetaja: No see ta ongi nagu see. Vaata, näed, sa tahad punast sinna aja? Vaata, sul on nagu kustutud. Ma tahaks sul tahaks kandida.
Õpetaja: Hakkab pihta See võibolla siit niiöelda
Õpetaja: Ee, silmadega. Nagu näha, mis? Otseselt nagu on,
Õpetaja: Seda ei pruugi joonistada ma seda nagu varem Tegelikult pihta. Jah,
Õpetaja: oskan nagu üles leida.
Õpetaja: Esiteks, selles mõttes, et foorum vajaks ka üldse päriselt mingisugust. Siis vaata, kui sa vajutad seda džene, Vaata,
Õpetaja: kuidagi on täiesti, väga varakult. Ee, näitab siin iooni. Vaata, et mis sa nagu selle
Õpetaja: see ei pruugi veel ka olla. Vaata meie kurja juurde. Fakt on see, et kuskil on nagu nimi, sümbol või midagi on nagu tegelikult ikkagi vanasti.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga nagu, peaaegu umbes aru saada, et kus ta kätte läheb. Siin ta annab. Esiteks, kaugel infot algab ja
Õpetaja: mina ei ole kindel, et input on ee kirjutatud ja Sellepärast proovime ka. Võin selle, okei onju? Selle alguses
Õpetaja: nii ei kenasti juhtumärkide sees.
Õpetaja: Kustutame selle osa, ja
Õpetaja: okei ütleb seda, et kui sealt, Okei, et, ee. See ei ole nagu otseselt erinev viga.
Õpetaja: Ma nagu ka ei saa aru. Ee, mis on nagu su indeksis vaja on
Õpetaja: Aga proovime leida. Muidugi, jah,
Õpetaja: Ja isegi siin ta seda niimoodi nagu näitab. Ma ütlen, et probleem on tegelikult ikkagi kuskil üleval pool.
Õpetaja: Aga Aga kas ta tingimata ennast nagu märku vaid kas talle nagu on niisugune asjale?
Õpetaja: Sa võid seda pärast hiljem proovida. Noh, see on ka See asi, mida saaks, nagu püsida. Vaata, mis mul on ka natuke raskusega nende asjadega.
Õpetaja: Ee, leida ülesanne. Saad öelda, et nagu öeldud, et Mul on nagu. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kliendi võtavad. Midagi on valesti, vaata. Ja.
Õpetaja: Aga nagu järgi tulemus on praegu niimoodi, et komisid ära, seal Lihtsalt ütle, muudab ära.
Õpetaja: No samamoodi vaata panna. Aga sa oled pakud.
Õpetaja: Mul On tore aru saada, et läbi vaataja tuleb, tegi selle põldu ära, et, ee, otsib üle
Õpetaja: Asi on ka üks.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Teine jääb sulle kunagi vaadata, onju Selles? Mõttes, Aga vaata, siin on ikkagi midagi mis peaks olema, aga näitab ikkagi. Vaata, et sul on see projekt. Ei,
Õpetaja: ja tegelikult ei ole ju kõik. Või noh, ma. Mul on, Mul on nagu internet Sul on. Vaata, onju? Selles on küsimus.
Õpetaja: Ma natukene kahtlustan seda, et keskkonna väikse restoran. Äkki peab olema kogu miinus
Õpetaja: Seal ei peaks olema, Aga ma korra vaatan endale üle. Äkki mul on ka see. Tundub nagu see, et mingil põhjusel praegu näitajad
Õpetaja: ega Mul oli ka just niimoodi, et vastakas kukkus.
Õpetaja: Ee, ega ma väga ei vaadanud.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei, mul ei ole ühtegi viga.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ee, sellepärast, et. Noh, vaata, on see, et sa võtsid praegu just. Ee. Tähtajad võtsid sama tähtajad täpselt samasuguse koodid, nagu ei näita. Vaata, see on viga. See on ikkagi küsimus. Nagu, et, ee. Noh, kui koodibaas on täpselt sama, siis nagu näitama, sul on
Õpetaja: populis.
Õpetaja: Näitas siis nagu küsimus on see, et kas ta on
Õpetaja: V kahe peale ja vaatame, nagu seal on viga või Ei ole viga
Õpetaja: seda, et ta väga hästi Praegu ei käitu.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Läks aasta lõpuni teinud, onju? Aga lähme lõpuni. Ta Teeb seda uuesti
Õpetaja: võis ka olla niimoodi see, et, noh, silmali ma küll näinud. Vot
Õpetaja: ja see foor. Ee, on üldse mõistlik ma. Ei saa ju huvitav.
Õpetaja: Mm.
Õpetaja: Ei. Saa väga usaldada seda kuidas,
Õpetaja: okei. Ee, jah, ee, peaks. See on praegu jama lahkuda. Ee, jah, huvitav,
Õpetaja: jah.
Õpetaja: Jah, mm. Ma ei saa.
Õpetaja: Unistus.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: nii närvi. Ainult
Õpetaja: rahulikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, kasutada. Neid
Õpetaja: ei vääri küünlaid nagu, ee.
Õpetaja: Kuulge, selline asi, et ma ära unustaks ka, ee paar asja, et see on kõik kohal, Meil tegelikult. Ja Jaanik Jaanik
Õpetaja: ee. Eestis. Täna ma kell neli näen Ära Aa, ma tegelikult jätaks teile paar teemat. Mida siis, Aa, võiksite lihtsalt ise natukene vaadata.
Õpetaja: Tuletage mulle siis Võibolla äkki mingi kümme minutit enne
Õpetaja: kas. Meil tuleb üks paus veel või ei tule? Vaata, Siin, on praegult.
Õpetaja: Jah, Ma enne nelja. Ma igal juhul midagi. Kümme. Minutit enne nelja enne nelja vaata. Lõpetaks, nagu töö ära Vaatame otsin, teile Mõned teemad, mida võiks hakata, veidi uurima ja vaatama.
Õpetaja: Kokkulepe on siis selles mõttes selline. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: Aa, lints tuleb ka korraks. Siia Vaata, et kui teil on mingisuguseid korralduslikke küsimusi või mistahes mingisuguseid. Ee, väljapoolseid koolitusteemaseid asju siis te saate temaga ka rääkida. Teate, korraks tuleb siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, te võiksite siis vähemalt nagu mingi pooltunnikese olla siin rahulikult, tõesti. Siis proovida vaadata neid teemasid, mida? Vaatame äkki Soome, nagu suhtleme Nendel asjadel ka. Ja siis minu pärast olete vabad.
Õpetaja: Ja kui kellegil on tõesti vaja kohe koju minna, ka midagi muud, siis võite koju minna, aga siis võiks kindlasti vaadata. Ära teemad.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd Teine asi, mida arutada. Aa, selles mõttes tuleb üks vestlus, Võibolla veel, et Jaaniku käest küsima
Õpetaja: Aa, meil on siukene võimalus või midagi. Mida me arutaksime teiega kaasa?
Õpetaja: Me Võime teha niimoodi. Näiteks, et kuskil teise nädala, võibolla Lõpus. Näiteks reede. See ei pea olema tingimata just see päev. Me võime teha ühe puhkepäeva.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga siis see teeks niimoodi. Ee, see Koolitus siis ei lõpeks kuuenda nädala reedel. Ära vaid siis seitsmenda nädala esmaspäeval. Ja see oleks puhtalt Demode päev. See on see päev, kus Me teeme demosid,
Õpetaja: et jätan siis võibolla teie eelt otsustada. Ee, et kas te soovite, et me teeme niimoodi? Ma ütlen ka, nagu mis see eesmärk on. Ja miks sa. Nagu. Miks me seda teha tahaks? Üks asi on see, et väga tore oleks üks puhkepäev, kui me Tavaliselt tuleme mingi ringi. Püha siis tavaliselt niimoodi lähebki. See asi läheb nihkesse.
Õpetaja: Aga teine asi, mis me taas sellega võidame on see, et Kui teil on see demodepäev, ei ole see viimane reede, vaid on hoopis esmaspäev. Siis on veel üks nädalavahetus, kus saab natuke viimast lihvi anda. Kes tahab,
Õpetaja: ei ole kuidagi kohustuslik.
Õpetaja: Aa, et siis, ee. Mis on nagu need positiivsed. On See, et, ee, tekib üks puhkepäev
Õpetaja: Aa, Ja Siis on niimoodi, et esmas, Sest et see uus koolitus, kes selle seitsmenädalase kampaaniaga läheb. Nii öelda. Ütleme siis teil koolitus algabki teisipäev Niikuinii me me seda saime nihutada juba nagu ametlikult.
Õpetaja: Aga se selle ühe päeva pausi ja nihutamise. See oleks selles mõttes mitteametlik ja paberite järgi. On justkui, et oli kuus nädalat. Ee, jutti, onju? Aga tegelikult on siis ee, kuskil üks vaba päev.
Õpetaja: Kohe pean midagi otsustama Võime homme arutada seda siis, kui jaanika on ka. Aga teised saavad siis juba natuke rohkem mõelda, et kas nagu jah või ei, ja siis Me võime isegi kokku leppida, et millal me seda tahaks teha? On ju ühte vaba päeva
Õpetaja: variant.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuupäevast kui Aa potensiaalsest pausist või Kuupäevast? Jah, et. No vaatame korra kliendile otsa. Ee, mul on. Olete ju Screenshare on peal pausis teinud Panemata on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, tühja Sellega Kui ma teen kalendri lahti korra.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on meie esimene nädal, on ju? Ee, on esimene. Nädal on teine nädal nii põmm. See on teine nädal. See on meie kolmanda nädala lõpp. Neljanda nädala lõpp. Viienda nädala lõpp kuuenda nädala lõpp. On siin
Õpetaja: siis. Aa, kui oi, Aga kergele see ei toimi niikuinii. Sorry,
Õpetaja: Teeme niimoodi, et ma tulen selle jutuga teie juurde tagasi.
Õpetaja: Siin on veel mõned väiksed nüansid mida peab koera läbi mõtlema. Aga muidu see plaan oleks siis selline idee järgi, et kui siin lõppeks, ära see kuus nädalat ja presentatsioon siin Sellel reedel. Kui meil tuleb üks paus sisse, siis lihtsalt demode päev ei ole mitte see viimane reede,
Õpetaja: vaid sellest järgneb esmaspäev, Kas mõte on Selge.
Õpetaja: No väga hea. Siis on otsustatud. Siis on lihtne.
Õpetaja: Siis teeme nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas?
Õpetaja: Aga see on niikuinii juba see. Oli meil juba varasemalt pandud. Ee, nihkesse, et ee. See nädal seitse algabki kuuendal
Õpetaja: ja lõppeb.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei, kaksteist. On Siis viimane.
Õpetaja: Ei, see ei lähe Kuidagi nihkesse vaatad. Ütleme niimoodi, et küsimus ongi see, et vaata, et kas see demodepäev on siin ja jätkub see järgmine nädal Vaata, mis On see noorem? Ai nädal on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, või? Või on lihtsalt niimoodi, et. Ee, reedel teeme siin. Ee, kergitame kaabut. Aa, ütleme kõigile. Tsau, Baka. Vaata, siin on teil puhkepäev
Õpetaja: Ja siit tuleb noorema, Sest et see oli juba väl. Probleem oli see, et me ei saanud seda enam muuta. Vaata, kuna meil oli see juba töötukassa ja nende kaudu kõik reklaamitud välja. Me ei saanud seda ee, kursust muuta, aga selle teise koolitusega. Me saime seda nihkesse panna. Edaspidi me hakkamegi tegema niimoodi et see on alati nihkes
Õpetaja: üks temadepäev.
Õpetaja: Aa, lihtsalt see vahe Olekski lihtsalt see, et. Noh, selles mõttes demodepäev on muidugi niuke ka. Vaata, et, ee, seal ei pea olema terve meeskond kohal
Õpetaja: keegi representib, Onju, et ta tööd sellel päeval enam tegelt ei tee.
Õpetaja: Nagu arendust.
Õpetaja: Temadepäev on temadepäev.
Õpetaja: Klassikaliselt teeme niimoodi, et see teeme tema ära, siis Kuskil mina ei tea kuskil kahe aeg see lõppeb. Siis me läheme. Teeme koos ühe ühise mingi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui keegi tahab veel teha kuskilt ringi, siis mingi seltskond tuleb ringi ja siis on see kõik. On ju
Õpetaja: neljapäev.
Õpetaja: Sooshop.
Õpetaja: Aa jaa. No seda saame ka arutada. Vaata jah, Et kas tahame neljapäeval minna? Teha lihtsalt ühe väikse ringi?
Õpetaja: Selle
Õpetaja: Me võime ka teha niimoodi, et me teeme selle järgmine neljapäev, kui me Oleme veits nagu üksteisega. Rohkem Ee, sõbru näinud.
Õpetaja: Jah, rohkem nutnud
Õpetaja: seda selles mõttes. See on Niukene Vaba kava Vaata, et sellisel tingimata ma ütlen. Ma tulen, kui ma saan. Ma ei tule, kui ma ei saa.
Õpetaja: Praegu on hetkel pigem kodus. Niuksed, kiired ajad, niukest asju on vaja teha, et kapad koju ja teed midagi, Onju? Mingid ehituse värgid, et vaja seal aias võttes toimetada?
Õpetaja: Ee, aga jah, seda võib ka arutada. Aga see on nagu rohkem selles mõttes vaba kava, et
Õpetaja: kui me seda teeme, niiöelda suures suures määras, me võime teha niimoodi, et Tõmbame kell neli joone alla ja läheme Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: teeme ühed ringi.
Õpetaja: Ee, kas esimene september on tabas?
Õpetaja: Esimene september on alati eriline. See ei ole tavaline,
Õpetaja: aga ei selles mõttes. Ee, see päev ei ole nagu selles mõttes kuidagi ee. Eriline, et ta vaba päev, pole aga te Juba sellel ajal tegelikult teete projekte.
Õpetaja: Te olete selles mõttes iseenda. Aja Peremehed Vaata, on ju, et, ee. Kui keegi tahab hommikul minna mingi aktusele asju, siis ma arvan, et see suures pildis enam midagi väga ei muuda. Vaata ehk ka see on lubatud, et meil meil nagu Niukest akadeemilist koolitust Enam ei ela
Õpetaja: töötukassast. Kui. Noh, kui kõik jääb nii nagu on nagu, ee, siis mitte midagi ei muutu,
Õpetaja: siis on Niimoodi, et reedel saab otsa ja teisipäeval on noorem. Ai,
Õpetaja: seal me oleme ka Seal on tegelikult hädavajalik panna nihkesse. Vaata, et ee, eriti Selle noore mai puhul, mis on Niukene lühikene koolitus, et tegelikult korraks saaks natukene seedida,
Õpetaja: et nädalavahetus annab väga palju juurde, et isegi kas Saad teha või mitte. Vaata, on ju Aga see planeeritud tööd, tööd ja kavad jäävad ikka. Samaks maht ei muutu nagu otseselt, aga on Siis võimalik. Veel üks nädalavahetus. Noh, meil on neid gruppe olnd, kus riigipüha satub Ee, sinna kuue nädala sisse, siis ta automaatselt nihkub ka töötukassaga. Vaata,
Õpetaja: siis ta on nagu, võibolla planeeritud kujul olnud. Ja, noh, meil on olnud nagu, seda, et õpilastel on olnud parem vaata, kui Tuleb lihtsalt see üks nädalavahetus juurde. Kus Lihtsalt saab teha selle viimase lihvi. Vaata, nagu
Õpetaja: oma projektile,
Õpetaja: aga okei, no see sellega, see on Nii,
Õpetaja: ja mul vist. Tegelikult ma ise mõtlen ka, et ma tegelikult iseenda puhkust ja asju ka ei arvestanud, et ma siin suure suuga Mõtlen, et oleks tore, aga,
Õpetaja: ee. Ütleme niimoodi, et võibolla see isegi minu poolt ei mängiks enam välja.
Õpetaja: Sest ma tahaks ka ma ikka Projekte ikka tahaks näha nagu demode päev.
Õpetaja: Aga mul on esmaspäev vaba päev endal terve see nädal ja ma olen üldse kuskil välismaal, nii Et ma hakkan mõtlema, et vist
Õpetaja: loll inimene. Pakun teile midagi välja, mis võibolla ei olegi mõeldav, aga see see noorema ei arenda endale Niimoodi planeeritud niimoodi ja teadlikult nihkes. Edaspidi on me juba mõtlesime, et me teemegi need nihkes, et, ee,
Õpetaja: see hästi natukene, tõmbad maha, sest et Lõpus on ikkagi see. Aga kõik tahavad oma projekti teha. Võimalikult ilusalt ja hästi, Vaata aga siis kuidagi. See aeg saab hästi. Kiirelt otsa.
Õpetaja: Ja see üks nädalavahetus on täpselt see. Vaata, kus tegelikult on. Juba Niukene lihvimise faas ja teeb sellest. Noh, teemadepäevaks lihtsalt
Õpetaja: grammi võrra, nagu Ee, parema lahenduse. Kuna on veel võimalik
Õpetaja: mingid nurgad sirgeks tõmmata, aga hea küll. Kuulge, ärme rohkem aega kuluta.
Õpetaja: Ee, paneme edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Lingi. Jõudsime ära teha. Selle Tingimustega peaks justkui sinna minema. See väga tähtis polegi. Nüüd, Ee,
Õpetaja: checkboxid. Faili lisamine. Seda võib ka näidata, ega Me Otseselt Faili. Ei, lisa aga ta input I all on olemas selles mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ee, input ja f input file
Õpetaja: ja ei olegi mitte Midagi muud võib lihtsalt saata pensionile,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult on lihtsalt Niukene nupukene Juice File.
Õpetaja: Kui vajutad seda lahti, Vahet pole Mac, Linux või Windows, Ta Siis teeb vastava programmi lahti, millega on võimalik Faile avada.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea, Saan valida see kaart näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ega ta ei näita midagi. Ega ta midagi ta taustal nii palju teeb, et tegelikult need andmed. Nagu ütleme, siis Html I mõtted Browser I mõttes kuskile justkui Tekivad,
Õpetaja: mida on võimalik kätteprogrammiliselt saada.
Õpetaja: Just, File.
Õpetaja: Noh, toimib teil samamoodi. Ei tohiks olla kuidagi teistmoodi Valid, mis iganes Faili ega ta kuhugi ei lähe praegu. Meil ei ole mitte midagi. See on nagu programmeeritud, et midagi peaks toimuma.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, Filefil Iks. Ja ma siia kustutan Ära Pole seda vaja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Järgmine asi, millest ma tahan rääkida, on.
Õpetaja: Pakkuge, mis see diiv võib. Olla? Tiiv on Selline jagamine on Mingi Jagamine on.
Õpetaja: Kuidas?
Õpetaja: See on nagu sisuala? Jah, põhimõtteliselt see div on nüüd selles mõttes täiesti nähtamatu, et kui ma teen siia div,
Õpetaja: ei näe siin mingisugust kasti ega mitte midagi. Ta ei olegi mingi konkreetne element, vaid ta on mõeldud hoopis selle jaoks, et sa, saad ise sellest põhimõtteliselt midagi meisterdada.
Õpetaja: Ja tiividel on nagu Niukene jaotus, et ee, idega saab samamoodi teha seda, et siin on Ee lapsed ja lapselapsed.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma küsin praegult. Ee, kes on see,
Õpetaja: kes on see div ülemisele div Ile?
Õpetaja: Mis ta on, Laps,
Õpetaja: Kes on need kaks Divi omavahel.
Õpetaja: Mhmh mu õde ja vend, Kes on ka need kaks? Div I sellele Div Ile
Õpetaja: lapsed on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis siia sisse saaks tekitada veel mingit ja nii edasi ja nii edasi, saate aru.
Õpetaja: Need asjad ei ole mitte kuidagi nagu Id, aga niipea kui hakata nendele mingit stiili juurde andma,
Õpetaja: siis nad võivad muutuda. Milleks iganes, Näiteks
Õpetaja: ka enda mõttes. Võime mõelda, et see siin on tabel.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma Korra panen selle teeme, selle, ma ma teen. See on nagu vaatamise koht siin. Kõik kõlab kõige hästi. Nagu värk. Enam Ma lähen Tabeli juurde. Esimene esimene rida on tabel ja siis tuleb ro, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma saaks teha tegelikult täpselt samamoodi dividega, nagu et
Õpetaja: see esimene Tiiv on tabel. Järgmine tiiv on table. Row
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Tabel Row.
Õpetaja: Siit. Siis tuleb diagramm või data? Vaata nagu veerg,
Õpetaja: aga see saaks Samamoodi tegelikult olla lihtsalt divn.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma tahaksin, siis ma saaksin ee, nüüd. Ee niiöelda stiilisätetega. Lihtsalt tekitada temas täpselt nagu tavaline tabel. No problem,
Õpetaja: kuidas See asi nagu päriselt siis mängibki? Rolli ongi see, kui me hakkame andma näiteks seda seda Div I ei ole mitte kuidagi näha, aga ma tulen. Noh, see kuskil. Ma panen korra. Lihtsalt test. Üks, kaks, kolm,
Õpetaja: teist, üks, kaks, kolm, Kus meil see test Üks, kaks, kolm on on siin.
Õpetaja: Hetkel sellel Tv. Il ei ole nagu mingisugust. Aa sisu. Ee, Teeme korra test. Aa,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, Null, null, Null
Õpetaja: on mingi tekst. Vaata ja nad on omavahel selles mõttes lahku lükatud. Nagu Vaata, lükkab nad erinevale reale, on ju nii
Õpetaja: Tesla Null, null,
Õpetaja: test üks, kaks, kolm. Võib öelda, et see test. Üks, kaks, kolm, on test, null. Nulli laps saaks nii öelda, kui Ma paneksin sellele Tv le juurde. Näiteks stiili Ee Background Color.
Õpetaja: Siis on nagu tekib midagi nähtavat. Ja panen. Näiteks Red,
Õpetaja: Siis nad mõlemad on Reed Id on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui ma tuleksin, paneksin sellele Tv le stiil
Õpetaja: ja paneks background color ja panen näiteks Screen
Õpetaja: aru. Vaata põhimõtteliselt See meil on nagu terve hulk igasuguseid eelnevalt defineeritud Html standardile vastavaid elemente.
Õpetaja: Mis siis, käituvad Brauseris ee kindlal viisil saavad võtta mingeid omadusi sisse ja nii edasi. Aga kõige muu jaoks on põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Me saame teha põhimõtteliselt mida iganes,
Õpetaja: et me saame teha igasugust struktuuri Aa stiili,
Õpetaja: Kas siin. On mingid veerud? Kastid, pildid, nagu. Noh, see on nagu nendega. On võimalik seda struktuuri mängida. Vaata, siin muidugi mängib rolli see omavahel ja suht nagu need suhtud sidemed. Vaata, et nad on üksteise sees, Kuidagi onju. Kuidas nad paiknevad?
Õpetaja: Sa saad küll lükata. Lahku kas ülesse ja alla. Vaata aga Põhimõtteliselt järjekorda sa nagu kuidagi muuta ei saa, et see. See annab meile põhimõtteliselt niukse custom struktuuri ja me Saame teha mida iganes,
Õpetaja: et väga palju tegelikult veebilehtedest ongi. Tegelikult nende tiibide peale ehitatud. Võtame kaskui Jällegi Mitte sponsor kino, aga lihtsalt nemad,
Õpetaja: Kui, Ee, Noh, tegelt Jah Apollo kino on minu vastu hea olnud. Ikka vahepeal. Kinkekad jagavad mulle aga küll, teistel põhjustel,
Õpetaja: et kui võtta See sama lehekülg niiöelda pilbasteks. Jälle source iga.
Õpetaja: Noh, lähme kuskile siia allapoole.
Õpetaja: No saate ma üldiselt aru,
Õpetaja: et ee, nendega on võimalik siis Ee midagi teha. See rohkem muutub rohkem meiningful, Iks, Kui me hakkame päris asja tegema.
Õpetaja: Divid on seal. Meie sõbrad teed on Devidas tee unitas ja teed Need devaidavad.
Õpetaja: Devider, On ta siis tõesti mõte järgi?
Õpetaja: Nii, ma võtan praegult selle jama siit ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja Vaatame, järgmist asju veel. Viimane asi. Pattan,
Õpetaja: Pata on tegelikult. Patonit saab igatepidi teha.
Õpetaja: Nagu selles mõttes, et on olemas Niuke element, nagu pattan,
Õpetaja: kui ma Praegu lähen Lingile siia lehele niiöelda tagasi. Ega teda väga näha pole. On siin all. Näete see väike plönn.
Õpetaja: Ma panen paar break i siia juurde, et, ee, ta muutuks natuke nähtavamaks, et saan scrollida. Näete seda nuppu?
Õpetaja: Miks ta Niukene väike plönn on see, et seal nupul pole praegu mitte mingit sisu. Ta on kahe tag iga element.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia näiteks lisaklient.
Õpetaja: Liisa uus klient.
Õpetaja: No siis see patal muutub Juba natuke rohkem nähtavamaks saab siia vajutada. Peale niimoodi
Õpetaja: Midagi ei toimu justkui saaks olla, et siia panen. Mingi Aa, siia Panen siia, panen Kümme
Õpetaja: Siia pane. Linna mida. Iganes onju, nõustan? Tingimustega et, lisaos Klient peaks siis ka enda nagu päriselus lisama uue kliendisüsteemi näiteks, Korja mõned andmed.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: teietatakse.
Õpetaja: Ma tunnen. Okei, Viisakas inimene. Midagi ei ole teha.
Õpetaja: Olgu see viimane kord
Õpetaja: et seda patelit tegelikult saab ee igat pidi teha. Ma saan tegelikult teha täiesti tavalise Tv I ka.
Õpetaja: Ja teha ta selliseks, et ta on klikitav. Saan talle anda nupu kujunduse, saan Näiteks Linki. Aa, see sama link. Tingimused.
Õpetaja: Näiteks. Ee, see siin. Seda on võimalik disainida nupuks,
Õpetaja: aga, noh, Button on selles mõttes ikkagi hea, Vaata, et koodi mõttes. Kui sa näed sõna Button, siis sa tead, et tegemist on Button versus, et sul on mingi div ja siis Mingi stiiliga. Ta muutub nagu nupuks. On ju
Õpetaja: et loomulikult, ee. Seal on sisse ehitatud funktsionaalsus.
Õpetaja: On see, mis me taga ajame
Õpetaja: aga nagu Printsiibis. Lihtsalt kui kuskil nagu patt on nagu seab ise mingid piirid, et sellega kuidagi mingi jama on. Vaata, siis alati saab lihtsalt mingisugusest teisest elemendist teha ka nupu tükitama Nupu. Ta lihtsalt on kõik kohe olemas. Vaata, lähed tema peale.
Õpetaja: On tal see käekene, onju? Saad aru, et saab klikkida ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Tabiga saab tema peale võibolla tulla.
Õpetaja: Ma klikin kuhugi.
Õpetaja: Noh, saab tulla, saab entrit vajutada. Ühik, Ma ei tea, ei paista sealt välja. Väga Seda vajutab või mitte.
Õpetaja: Ee, Davai. Järgmine asi. Stiilid
Õpetaja: Css. No võib korra lugeda teksti, aga ega seal Midagi väga lugeda pole, aga vaatame siis sellegipoolest.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: Css. Kõigepealt saaks pihta agronüümist, et, ee, millest need tähed tulevad? Css tähistab kas Lehti.
Õpetaja: Tegemist on Cdilehe keelega, mida kasutatakse Html dokumendi välimuse vormingu kirjeldamiseks. Cssi kasutatakse peamiselt veebidisainis võimaldades arendajatel disaineritel kontrollida veebilehe paigutust värve tüpograafid Ja muid visuaalseid aspekte
Õpetaja: peamine eesmärk on eraldada Htm, eraldada Sisu Noh, Atml ja esitlus.
Õpetaja: Ja see eraldada. See on see võtmesõna üldse progemises Meile meeldib ee. Asju eraldada.
Õpetaja: Ühetaolised asjad ühte kohta ja teised asjad teise kohta. Aga me eraldame need. Me ei hoia neid koos.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis veel see on? Tema peamine värk.
Õpetaja: Mis ta eelised on? Ee, paremini hooldatav taaskasutus.
Õpetaja: Ee, ligipääsetavus.
Õpetaja: Ee, mahu vähendamine
Õpetaja: Stiili saab rõkendada kolmel viisil. Ee, ja me nüüd räägime üheksakümnendatest. Tänapäeva tulek. Esimene värk on reasisene stiil.
Õpetaja: Siis on stiilid, mis on küll, nagu, Aa,
Õpetaja: ära defineeritud Aga Html I sees ja viimane variant on siis eraldi Css failid.
Õpetaja: Kus on definitsioonid? Hakkame kohe nüüd kõiki vaatama.
Õpetaja: Selektoritest. Ma räägin, ise,
Õpetaja: Hakkame siis pihta kuskilt ee ülevalt. Näiteks see sama meie pank hetkel. Mis värvi ta on.
Õpetaja: Musta värvi vastab tõele. Värvidega on lihtsalt kõige lihtsam mängida praegu.
Õpetaja: Vanakooli värk.
Õpetaja: Vanakooli värk oligi, et kasutajad atribuuti Style
Õpetaja: ja siis kasutad ee, konkreetseid ee parameetreid, mis sind huvitab näiteks noh Background Color.
Õpetaja: Ja Oot, oot, oot, mis me selle selle läheme? Teeme ikka kohe Päris üheksakümnendate stiili. Body blokk, ehk siis kogu nähtav osa
Õpetaja: Style Background Color.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ootasin seda tegelt. Noh, hakkab minema. Juba
Õpetaja: alustame, et sellise. See on nüüd nagu nendest kõige see vanem variant, Kuidas seda asja teha Ja siis kuidas edasi tehti?
Õpetaja: No loomulikult on vaja siin ka mingisugune stiil teha.
Õpetaja: Background Color. Violet, Aitäh, Eriti äge pank. Teeme mingi paragrahvi ka. Oi, see on kole. Teeme listi.
Õpetaja: Style.
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt kõige lihtsam värvid. Meil veel seal on, Blue, No Seda ei näegi peaaegu.
Õpetaja: Mm, Corn Flower Blue. Noh,
Õpetaja: noh, okei, see on Niukene Ja nüüd saaks teha mingeid muid asju ka nagu näiteks, Ee, võtame selle Sama pangakontori, kus ta nüüd jäi. Mul siin siin.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen stiili Booking. Ma ei mäleta, kas see on Semi Pakuks On Ei ole tühikuga.
Õpetaja: Ee, tühiku. Kaisa, oota. Ma olen siin Stiili bloki sees. Vot siin hoopis nii. Ütleme näiteks Border Border.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtame korra suus. Kolor.
Õpetaja: Ei, niimoodi ei taha päris. Paneme lihtsalt. Ee Lack, kas tuli midagi
Õpetaja: Tegelikult, Tal on vaja ka veel seda, et ta on solid. On üldse Border.
Õpetaja: Ma ei oska niimoodi peast teha. Borders olid Borderstyle.
Õpetaja: Äkki siin saab panna, et ta on, ee, muidugi, Dash.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, kuidagi saab nüüd vilkuma ka veel panna. Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: Saate. Mõttest aru, et ee, iga Html I sisene stiil,
Õpetaja: mis nüüd on nagu pa lugu on siis see. Vaata, et kui meil on Aa mingisugune monster veebilehekülg, ma seda näidet ma olengi toonud. Teen siin korra varem välja. Toon seal umbes siin, ära et vaatame, et meil on igal pool. Mingid headerid, on mingid punased
Õpetaja: ja siis tuleb ja ütleb, et, Ee, kuulge, punane ei sobi hoopis. Avo, Palun tehke.
Õpetaja: No siis olekski see, et kui need on nende Html i sisesed niiöelda koodilõiked, siis Me Igal pool peaks hakkama otsima.
Õpetaja: See asi, nagu selles mõttes oli nagu paganama tüütu, Et siis kuidagi asjad läksid selle standardis edasi.
Õpetaja: Siis oli selline mõte.
Õpetaja: Aga mis siis, kui me teeme niimoodi, et see on selles head sektsioonis?
Õpetaja: Ma korra võib olla. Kustutan need kõik Ära Vaata, et värvid peaksid siit ära minema.
Õpetaja: Noh, nii siis tuli selline mõte nagu et. Mis siis, kui meil on siin selles head I Sees Stiiliplokk.
Õpetaja: Style. See on nüüd see variant. Kaks, Vaata, mis ei ole. Nagu see, mida me otsime. Aga Ta on juba natuke lähemal sellel.
Õpetaja: Ja mis siis, kui me teeme niukse süsteemi? Vaata, et me saame mõelda Aa niukse lähenemise, et, ee, ma alustan siis nagu Aa Selles stiilis ebatäpsem täpsemaks,
Õpetaja: vastab tõele, et meil on, ee, neid H El Neli elemente siin. Päris mitu korda. Eriti Äge pank, meie kontor, pea igas kohas. Ma lihtsalt valisin h neli. Enamus,
Õpetaja: et ma saan siin stiiliblokis öelda. See on nüüd ebatäpsemalt Täpsemalt suunalt liigume, et ee, Kõik H. Neljad
Õpetaja: nende background Color oleks aqua para
Õpetaja: saate mõttest aru, et ee, siin on, niimoodi et me ütleme Elemenditüübile, ütleme, et sellel Lehel indeks. Punkt Atml. Siin, sellel lehel.
Õpetaja: Kõik H. Neljad saavad sellise stiili
Õpetaja: No siin. Saaks teha samamoodi mis ma panin seal ise enne Kirjutasin Ee, veel. Mm,
Õpetaja: mis asi oli? Border Style oli? Vist onju Border Style Dash.
Õpetaja: Ohoh, noh, nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd See on nagu sellise täpsusega, Et, Ee,
Õpetaja: kõik H. Neli niiöelda saavad sellise stiili.
Õpetaja: Aga see asi nagu selles mõttes läheb natukene edasi.
Õpetaja: Ma saan nendele H neljedele lihtsalt mõelda, ma saan mõelda mingi oma stiili välja oma klassi, mida ma saan anda mitmele elemendile.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Kuidas see asi töötab? See tegelikult käib niimoodi. Vaata, et see Html nagu renderdatakse lahti. Ja see stiil lihtsalt otsib üle. Vaata, et kas kuskil on H neli. Tee see värvi. Kas kuskil on H Neli? Tee see seda värvi. See mõte on nii See on selektor. Hetkel lihtsalt selekteerime lihtsalt kõiki niiöelda html niiöelda elemente ise
Õpetaja: ja värvime neid ja sti stiliseerime neid.
Õpetaja: Aga saad ise välja mõelda mingisuguse klassi. Ja siis on niimoodi, et sa pead kõigepealt Alustama punktiga punkt. Mõtled mingi nime välja?
Õpetaja: Noh, paneme oso Ee, Purple näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ma ise mõtlen mingi suvalise nime välja
Õpetaja: ja ma ütlen, et, Ee, et kus iganes keegi viitab Auwson Purple Ile, siis ole hea. Värvi selle background Color
Õpetaja: punaseks.
Õpetaja: Hetkel, kui ma tulen siia, peale, siis Mitte midagi ei muutu sellepärast, et hetkel on lihtsalt definitsioon,
Õpetaja: et kõik klassid nimega on read. Mis liiding on see vajalet?
Õpetaja: Paneme pru vahele, Et
Õpetaja: või kuidas Ma saan öelda, vaata, et see on nagu stiilid, et siin lehel hakka otsima
Õpetaja: kõike H. Neljasi ja kujunda hakka otsima Kõike klasse, mis on klassifitseeritud Purple ja värvina. Kuidas ma seda saan teha? See punkt ütleb tegemist on klassiga.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma nüüd võtan Mingisuguse elemendi. Ma võtan mingi. Mis asi on Näiteks meie kliendid. Kus see meie kliendid on? Siin
Õpetaja: see teine, Siis mina saan öelda. Kuule, Saa sina kujundus klassilt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see tähendab seda, et see leht nagu põhimõtteliselt laetakse. Ära vaata. Ja nüüd see põhimõtteliselt otsib igalt poolt ülesse
Õpetaja: Kas ma näen kuskil? Ee, kui jah, siis need stiilid kohanduvad. Seda peab mõtlema natukene kui te. Noh, päriselt tehniliselt võttes niipidi on aga See Html laetakse ja nüüd üks haaval hakkavad stiilid kohanduma. Kõigepealt vaatan kõik H. Neli ütleb seda, et ee, on ju Aqua Onju
Õpetaja: Ja Dash.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me näeme, et meie kliendid
Õpetaja: ei ole enam Ee Aqua. Mis? Sest, et H. Neli kõike nagu H neljad
Õpetaja: siin võib olla paragrahv. Siin võib olla Body, vaata. Noh, teeme body.
Õpetaja: Body. Kogu body. On.
Õpetaja: No korra Oli Agoga mingi asi sõidab tast üle praegu ära, onju? See H Neli on parem näide, et ju tegelikult esimesel ringil ta tuleb ja väärib selle aguaks ja paneb raamid,
Õpetaja: ta tuleb, Värvib selle agaks ja paneb raamid. Ta tuleb, värvib ja paneb agvaks ja paneb raami. Ta selectib veel.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lihtsalt see esimene stiil on Ära tehtud. Nüüd. Ta läheb uuele ringile.
Õpetaja: Als One Purple.
Õpetaja: Kas sinul on Purple Ei ole. Kas sinul on Purple On, Aga nüüd ta kirjutab üle ainult background Color I
Õpetaja: Ainult Seda nüanssi eelmisest kihist, mis juba ära värviti. Borderstyle. Dasht on endiselt alles
Õpetaja: Kas kadeeruvad stiililehed Me Räägime nagu Mõelge nagu värvilöra.
Õpetaja: Mina panen siia ühe löraka ja see on kõik oranž.
Õpetaja: Siis mingi asi värvitakse nüansiks, Aga kui mingi teine asi tuleb, ütleb, et pool sinust on punane.
Õpetaja: Siis ta sõidab sust üle ja nüüd jääb
Õpetaja: alles see osa oranžist Ja see osast punasest, Mis peab olema, kui tuleb mingi kolmas? Äkki ei lähe,
Õpetaja: Mis ütleb ka, et täpselt see? See tuleb lihtsalt hiljem, et ole hoopis sinine see osa. No siis ta on sinine. Aga see osa ikka säilib. Me paneme lihtsalt niimoodi kihi kaupa. Paneme peale
Õpetaja: ja mis iganes on See lõpptulemus Ja see tuleb tulemus Siit lõpuks tuleb veel mingi.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea must mingis osas mingites asjades sõidab üle siis sõge
Õpetaja: pole ju sellest siukest joonist teinud. Aga näed,
Õpetaja: niimoodi võib seda mõelda, et see käib niimoodi, et, ee, need seaded lihtsalt panevad ülevalt alla. Ja otsivad. Kas ma leian vastet ja siis kohandavad seda stiili. No, kui me teeme seda edasi veel.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme siis ma teen selle lisa Uus kliendi teen ka koos. On otsinud. Kuidas Ee, oota, mis selle nimi on? Lisa Uus klient. See siin, ma ütlen siin Glass
Õpetaja: Also Purple.
Õpetaja: No oodatud tulemus on, et see on siis täpselt samasugune, on ju? Nii Mm, okei,
Õpetaja: mis te arvate, mis juhtub siis, kui ma Teen näiteks Niukse asja.
Õpetaja: Ah? Mis on selline,
Õpetaja: kui ma teen ühe niukse klassi juurde nagu ja ütlen, et Background Color on siis sellisel juhul. Green.
Õpetaja: Mis värvi on? Hetkel need kaks tükki, mis ennem olid Hiljad
Õpetaja: Miks rohelised?
Õpetaja: Ei, ma kirjutasin ühe uue definitsiooni ja see Hall viitab sellele, et seda ei ole kunagi kuskil Kasutatud Nad on endiselt
Õpetaja: lillal.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga võtame selle esimese. Meie kliendid. Nüüd on ju,
Õpetaja: kui Mina Tulen nüüd. Panen siia peale.
Õpetaja: Ma tulen nüüd siia. Selle meie kliendide juures, kus on öeldud, et saa sina oma stiil Als One
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen, et saa sinna. Oma. Mis värvi on meie kliendid ja miks pakuja roheline see on? Viimane
Õpetaja: on roheline meie kliendid.
Õpetaja: Okei, Aga mis siis, kui ma muudan nende järjekorra ära? Et Ma panen selle hoopis siia ettepoole. Ja Auston Purple on tagumine, mis värvi ta Nüüd on.
Õpetaja: Miks ta ikka roheline on?
Õpetaja: Järjekord.
Õpetaja: Jaa, sest et seal ees on järjekord. Näe, vaata, ta on ikka roheline.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ta Kõigepealt tuleb, värvib kõik need ära. Mis ta leiab, siis ta värvib kõik need ära. Nendes sätetes.
Õpetaja: Touch ei kao kuhugi.
Õpetaja: Ma saan öelda, et Owson Green iga näiteks, ee. Panen siis Style.
Õpetaja: Teemegi sellise huvitava asja. Vaata, Style.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ah, Borderstyle. Ma tahan meelega just Borderstyle panna Ja panen solid.
Õpetaja: Üks nagu sirge. Lihtsalt joon, vaata.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma küsin nüüd korra, et, ee, milline näeb välja siis meie?
Õpetaja: Mm, kus me Tegime seda nii. Üks mingi
Õpetaja: meie kliendid. Kus sa oled siin, meie kliendid.
Õpetaja: Et tal on Purple, on mõlemad. Ära pandud. On ka pandud. See H. Neli. Vaata, et siis, mis värvi tal teie arvates peaks olema Sest et see info on praegult siin,
Õpetaja: me teame, et kõik Kolm kohanduvad talle
Õpetaja: roheline Solid ongi nii. Vaata, sest et siin Background Color Aquaga sõidetakse üle ja ta on Aqua. Aga siis tuleb see Purple
Õpetaja: teeb Ta hoopis selle. Ja nüüd viimane teeb. Värv on igal juhul roheline.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me vaatame, seda et see ee, kõige lahjem, nagu et kõik H. Neljad. Olgu nemad, Dash.
Õpetaja: Aga siis lõpus. Ju Tegelikult seal on kasutatud. Siis Borderstyle on solid, Ta peaks olema roheline Ja solid.
Õpetaja: Ja nii on ka
Õpetaja: nii. Aga nüüd läheme samm edasi. Meil on nagu see, et meil on elemenditüüp Html nagu elemendi enda Tüüp kõige madalam. Siis on klass, mis on jagatud. Aga nüüd on veel midagi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen hashtag I praegult siia praegult kirja, siis Juba ta midagi pakub. Mida ta mulle pakub? Siin
Õpetaja: Mingid tuttavad sõnad. Vähemalt esimesed kaks. Võiksid olla Just Id. D
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et See on nüüd mõeldud niimoodi, et see lekti, et see stiil kohandub ainult nendele elementidele. Kus siis on vastava idee, kus siin me mõtlesime, välja mingi klassi nime ise
Õpetaja: ja seda kasutame allpool. Siis siin on natuke vastupidi.
Õpetaja: Sa saad viidata konkreetsele Id le, Kui ma panen first name ja panen selle. Background Color
Õpetaja: Panen näiteks. Ja ma ei tea, Yellow on või?
Õpetaja: Ah, see on nüüd see Ee, mis nüüd läks On ju? Sellel oli Ju Id First Name on nii,
Õpetaja: et siin on Nüüd, niimoodi vaata nägu, et selles mõttes. Noh, teame siis seda Natuke edasi. Vaata, ma panen selle meie kliendile. Panen ka mingi Id kõlge.
Õpetaja: Kus on meie kliendid? On Siin Ma ütlen temale, et temal on atribuut Id ja on Hour Customers.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tulen ja panen praegult selle asja nimeks Siin Hour Customers
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma küsin, et meie Kliendid. Mis värvi? On Background. Color.
Õpetaja: Hello a. Kui ma panen ta siia ülesse.
Õpetaja: Mis värvi ta on?
Õpetaja: Miks Okei, järjekord määrab? Loomulikult, ainult Siis kui need on sama taseme asjad. Näiteks, et siin jääb peale. Vaata, kui mõlemat on kasutatud, sest et ta on allpool.
Õpetaja: Aga kõigepealt ikka mängib rolli. Vaata see, et kas on Id klass või elemenditüüp, See on see järjekord.
Õpetaja: See on nagu siis täpsemalt ebatäpsemaks, mis? Ma Ütlesin, Kõige täpsem on Id. Siis tuleb klassifikatsioon. Siis tuleb elemenditüüp neid kombineerides.
Õpetaja: Okei, päris. Hea, Noh, mõtleme natukene edasi, veel, siis
Õpetaja: Okei, see saab olema põnev. Ma isegi. Ma isegi ei tea praegu, et ma ütlen. Nüüd ma ütlen, ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: Ma võtan selle, sest et Kõik asjad on meil selles. Aa, meie klientidel olemas. Tal on tema. Id on Hour Customer. Ta on H neli. Tal on siin klaas Ee, niiöelda kõik on olemas. See järjekord on niikuinii kama. Vaata, mis siin on. See niikuinii midagi ei muuda kunagi selle me juba tegime selgeks.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma tulen ja panen selle ee otsa lõpu hüüumärgi. Ja important.
Õpetaja: Mis värvi on nüüd? Meie kliendid? Ee, background.
Õpetaja: Mis te Arvate, sa määrasid tuleb prioriteed.
Õpetaja: Täpselt, See peaks olema idee järgi niimoodi. Et mis? Sest et tegelikult see Id on ju täpsem? Vaata, hei, See kohaldub sellele.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd mõelda Selle mõttes me ütleme, vahet pole. Vaata, kus sina oled
Õpetaja: See asi on nagu tähtsam, kui kõik muu.
Õpetaja: No Vaatame, kas on. Siis on
Õpetaja: meie kliendid on? Kui ma võtan selle. Nüüd on küsimus. Aga mis siis juhtub, kui ma panen hoopis selle sama asja siia lõppu. Green Ile important.
Õpetaja: Mis värvi ta nüüd see on?
Õpetaja: See on esimene,
Õpetaja: No aga ei ole ju viimane. Jääb Peale nüüd, kuidas see asi töötab, et. Okei, meil on siis nagu mitu asja, mis on kõigepealt, on nagu siis nende tüübid. Vaata, et Kas see on element? Kas see on klass või? See on Id No täpsustasemel.
Õpetaja: Siis järgmisena mängib. Mängu järjekord see, mis on all pool Ja loetakse viimasena. See värvib viimasena.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on vaja tähtis meeles ka hoida seda, et ainult ta värvib üle ainult need aspektid, mis ta Siis nagu üle värvib, et Vaata, et kas seal on see background või on border. Vaata, pannakse üle. On ju,
Õpetaja: et siin on nagu Erinevad aspektid, mida nagu meeles hoida, on see, et sa ei ole niimoodi. Et kui sa kohaldad mingisuguse ühe nagu klassi, vaata siis nagu Täiel määral Sõidad. Nagu kõigest üle. Vaatad kui ühes kohas on stiilid andnud nagu kolme nelja aspekti osas ja hiljem sõidad üle ainult väiksemas osas, siis see väiksem osa sõidab üle
Õpetaja: See tegelikult kõik See on. See on ideaalne, et see süsteem Niimoodi on nüüd see sõna Important on siis selline asi. Vaata, et see on nagu seda ei tohiks väga kergekäeliselt kuskil kasutada.
Õpetaja: Miks sellepärast, et importantilt ei ole enam veriimportandit ei tule
Õpetaja: Ja Ultra Important, Ma ei tea, universum Important pole ainult. On nagu selles mõttes ühe korra võimalik seda kasutada.
Õpetaja: Kus on see Kasulik on Näiteks see, et. Ee, kui teil on mingisugune raamistik ja asi. Ja te kasutate mingisugust asju, kus toodi järjest kujundusi ja asju
Õpetaja: See võib vahel olla hästi natukene. Tehniliselt keeruline. Vaata, et kui see praegu. Me tegime niimoodi, et see on siin Htmil Id sees, me Kohe nüüd. Järgmisena vaatame, kui. Ta on üldse stiilileht. Kuskil eraldi failina. Ega seal midagi väga ei muutu. Ee, topime nüüd eraldi faili ja Teeme ühe viite. Vaata, et. Noh,
Õpetaja: et palun vaata neid stiile. Vaata, onju? Siin kohalduvad need stiilid.
Õpetaja: See selleks. Ee,
Õpetaja: see on nagu see, et kui tegelikult neid stiili Css faile võib olla mitmeid, siis tegelikult Browser loe, laeb nad mingis järjekorras see kindlasti ei ole random, vaid Nad tulevad ikka mingis kindlas järjekorras. Selles mõttes deterministlik, et nad tulevad iga kokku. Vajutad Refresh I. Nad tulevad samas järjekorras,
Õpetaja: aga sul on mingi. Sul on mingi oma kood. Sul on mingid stiililehed. Sul on mingid lingid. Viited seal? Tegelikult, see järjekord võib natukene nagu mängida rolli Ja Siis võibolla just niimoodi. On see, et
Õpetaja: sul on vaja nagu. Et jääb maksma mingisugune mingis kohas sinu stiil. Vaata, sul on kuidagi Keeruline nagu kontrollida, et kuidas Brauser nad ikkagi siis lõpuks moodi järjekorda lähevad? Lõpuks. Mis moodi need järjekorda lähevad,
Õpetaja: Siis see important on veel võimalus, kuidas sa saad sada protsenti, sõita kõigest muust üle
Õpetaja: savi. See, et ma olen viim nagu esimene.
Õpetaja: See on just see, et ta Viimane jääb peale on ju? Kui sinu asjad laetakse esimesena, siis on ju nagu see, et mustmiljon asja tuleb, sõidab ülema stiilidega, Võibolla nagu Ei värvi Nagu mul seda Frontist seal selliseks nagu vaja Vaata, on ju siis see important on nagu veel see võimalus, et savi, mis Järjekorras laetakse. Mul on see vabadus.
Õpetaja: Aga niipea, kui ütleme kui sina, teeksid mingisuguse vahva mingi raamistiku või asja, mis aitab mingit stiile teha Ja Mida iganes, onju, kui sina oled juba seal kasutanud porgandit, siis on nagu see võimalus on kasutajal kadunud,
Õpetaja: et see peaks olema nagu, Et seda, et seda nagu. Kui sa teed oma programmis, teed neid stiile ja asju sätid. Vaata, seal. Sa pigem peaksid lahendama need mured nende järjekordade asjadega oma rakenduse sees ära, et väga nagu lihtsalt ei tohiks seda kasutada. Ma arvan seda Important It,
Õpetaja: sest et sellest on raske üles heita Sul endal võibolla, hiljem kuidagi ka otsida. Noh, enda projektile ligipääs, et kõike muuta. Muidugi on ju libraritega mitte nii väga,
Õpetaja: Et, ee. Põhimõtteliselt See on siis selline. Mängumaa on ka hea vaadata Mis järjekorras? Mis seda saab vaadata küll et. Ee, No ma nüüd Ei tea, meil on lokaal. Ee, värk. Ja meil on voe. Vaata, et kui ma inspektiga vaatan, Ee,
Õpetaja: aa kuskil peaks olema, siin samas Näed,
Õpetaja: Aa ja kuskil. Ma jään vastuse võlgu, kus ja kuidas Aga saab küll. Ma olen ise mässanud nendega, aga kuskil ta näitab. Vaata, Kõik see on kõik stiilid, mis tulevad kuskilt.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui sa selle elemendi valid, siis
Õpetaja: ma võibolla niimoodi. Jah, näiteks, ee. Siis ta peaks ütlema, et näe, ta saab Aa ja ta ütleb ka, kus see tegelikult tuleb. Vist
Õpetaja: vajab mingit ee Jama veits.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma proovin ka uuesti. Jah, saab küll. Ee, kuidagi saab.
Õpetaja: Ja Ja kindlasti on kuidagi võimalik ka siis, tegelikult, et mingisuguseid. Samme ee, niiöelda enda poolt, teha, Et seda järjekorda kuidagi kontrollida. Et, no ta. Jah. Ta ütleb, et see background Color, nagu sõidan,
Õpetaja: sõidetakse üle, aga ta viitabki sellele, Vaata, et et kuskil on mingi klass. Vaata mis Ee,
Õpetaja: Noh, vot see siin ongi see. Kui ma võtaksin võibolla selle välja, et siis tuleb väl nähtavale, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja siis see siis on nagu see, et mind sõidetakse üle.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt on see see. Vaata, kui sa võtad selle maha, Näed, mind ei sõideta üle.
Õpetaja: Ja see on üksjagu. Nagu mõtlemist ja arusaamist küll. Vaata et kuidas see asi töötab, aga ma ütlen, siin On ka see, et seda asja te ei pea nagu praegult. Ee, kuni. No ütleme seibideni enda peaks lahti mõtlema. Nagu, Vaata, et
Õpetaja: kui Te printsiibis lihtsalt saate aru, mis on teie jaoks tähtsad. Ma räägin ära. On see asi
Õpetaja: arusaamine sellest ja selle erinevusest
Õpetaja: me enamus ajast tegelikult Enamus arendused. Ee, väga tihti. No mina ei ole. Nagu ma ütlen, ma pole fronti kunagi arenenud ka sellisel kujul ma olen mingi Nipet näpet Ei olnud mingi Lhv mingit asju seal siin, seal näpima. Nagu. Aga see on. Kõik oli nagu teistmoodi Anguraris ka veel seal Veidi tehtud. Ee, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: aa. See kõige tähtsam osa, mis siin tegelikult on, Teada, et enamus ajast me kasutame taaskasutatavat klasse ja värve Kuidas saab seda defineerida punkti abil? Kuidas seda saab öelda, et kasuta kuskil. Aa, niiöelda elemendis on sõna. See on kõige tähtsam.
Õpetaja: Rohkem Tegelikult Ei olegi vaja teada.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt, sest, et see on see, kuidas me teeme.
Õpetaja: Asja Aga nüüd on nagu siis see, asi, et see asi Siin kõik on selle stiili bloki sees ja ta elab ainult indeks. Saate meil failis, onju? Aga kui meil on mingi põhimõtteliselt igalt poolt vaja ligi saada. Ja pealegi, äkki me tahame teha, et meil on, ee, mingisuguste erinevate sektsioonide jaoks Eraldi failid. Vaata, võibolla adminile
Õpetaja: on ühed Stiilid. Mingid lihtsad stiilid. Adminis reaktsioon. Vaata
Õpetaja: jah, nii palju kui ma hobi korras tegin, siis Esimene rakendus oli see, et kõik need stiilid Olid nagu, ee, äpi koodis. Ja see koot läks nii mõttetult pikaks ja nii raskeks, et nagu see rakendus muutus nii aeglaseks, sest ta Iga kord laadis neid stiile ja ja vaatas üle,
Õpetaja: et pigem hea siis importida need lihtsalt teised. Ee, teised lehed.
Õpetaja: See lause. Vaata, mis on siin Boldiga pandud. Ccs i peamine eesmärk on eraldada sisu esitlusest Html ja Css.
Õpetaja: Ee, me soovimegi seda teha. See nüüd tuleb selleks Ära vaata, kujutage ette meil. Oletame, et meil on neid faile nagu mingi lademetes ja igal pool stiiliblokis oleks need kujundused sellised. Ikka on See sama asi jälle. Vaata, tuleb. Vaata, Noh, parem on. Vaata vähem kohta kui sotsida. Vaata idee järgi, kui nad on nagu pilla peale laiali ja kuidagi nagu failide sees.
Õpetaja: Mõte on Jah, sama kui nad seal ikka tuleb. Sa ütleks, et muuda nagu ära
Õpetaja: mingisugune stiiliasi, siis on väga suur vahe. Kas ma lähen kuskile kausta minema ka? Css, kus on Mingid erinevad stiilifailid ja kond on natukene seal ja mudin neid asju Seal Vaatan tulemist, on koolide tee arendus läbi
Õpetaja: versus see, kus ma pean hakkama päriselt koodibaasi. Läbi käima, et ongi see mõte, Ongi see, et esiteks taaskasutatavus ka, et sa lood ühe korra mingid stiilid ja sa saad igal pool viidata neile. Hoiame sellega koodimahtu kokku Koodimaht tähendab reaalselt aega, kui kiirelt inimesel Browser is asi avaneb.
Õpetaja: No eriti telefoni ja kolm G puhul. Nagu. Vaata, mida väiksem on selle Lehe Mahtuda, kiiremini. Ta laeb, on ju? Me Tegelikult unustame seda natukene Ära vaata, et need kiirused, mis on nagu tänapäeval igalt poolt saadavad, on lihtsalt läinud nii kiireks. Vaata, igal pool kõik avaneb. See on ka natukene, Võibolla teinud Nagu arendajaid ka veidi laisaks
Õpetaja: ei ole nagu nii hullu rõhku. Vaata, selle. Hakkame mingeid kilobaite siin nüüd kokku hoidma.
Õpetaja: Aga tegelikult ikkagi igalt poolt natukene. Võidad, on ju? No see on Nagu raha kogumine. Vaata, kui sa säästad, käid poes ja saad siin. Ma ei tea, porgandi kilo on Kas ee.
Õpetaja: Kolmkümmend senti või viiskümmend senti, et see võib olla see Vahe. Ei olegi nii suur. Noh, see on. Isegi piisab protsentuaalselt. Suur. Ütleme, kas kümme senti oleks vahe vaata, et see võit on Võibolla väga väike, aga ütleme kuidagi. Lifetime.
Õpetaja: Ee, on see ikkagi mingisugune võit, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja mõne pingi arvuti ongi Ee, lihtsam ja aeglasem. Ja kui. Sul on vaja sinna koodi mingisugust kirjutada ja sa kirjutada sellise spageti, siis ta lihtsalt ei saagi sellega hakkama.
Õpetaja: Jaa, võib tekkida igasuguseid raskusi, Aga ma ütlen siin, kas igasugused muud võidud tuleb ka. Ma ütlengi see, kui mõnus on nagu see, Et kui sa pead mingisuguseid stiili asju minema muutma, siis sa tegelikult oma projektist tead, et mul on seal taustal ma ei üks kaks Stiililehte Võibolla. Võibolla on ainult üks. On ju.
Õpetaja: Lähen sinna. Vaatan sealt Sealt. Hakkad seda asja harutama. Vaata et kus, mis, mida
Õpetaja: Mängid korra seal mingisuguste sätetega teed? Mingi asja punaseks. Kuskil läheb midagi põlema.
Õpetaja: Noh, lihtne on ju, et, Ee, see on see, mõte kuidas seda siis teha.
Õpetaja: Ega siin midagi erilist ei olegi. Lihtsalt, Ee, tuleb. Noh, tavaliselt on jälle kuskil kataloogi ajal viisakalt Tavaliselt on kuskil Äkki all. Nad on praegu ka
Õpetaja: pildid. Ja üks asi. Kõik peaks olema seal.
Õpetaja: No ajutiselt teeme. Ee, new Mm. Styleshid võib ka panna lihtsalt faile punkt sees, sest sisevahet pole.
Õpetaja: Aga idee järgi New Styleshit ega ta midagi muud väga ei tee. On paar erinevat tüüpi. Ka ma neid teisi ei hakka rääkima. Ma isegi ei tea neid väga. Need on veel mingid kõrgemad asjad. Aga see vaikimisi on punkt. Sss,
Õpetaja: Ah noh, mina Ei tea, siia võib kohe panna mida iganes. Ee, lihtsalt Style Csss Hourstyle. Christmas Faili nimi, Faili nimi.
Õpetaja: Ma panen lihtsalt praegu Style punkt Sss.
Õpetaja: Noh, võime kiti lisada Ja Nüüd kõik need sätted, mis on siin Control Iks tuleb. Paned siia. Style I.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate kas Nüüd võiks Aa kõik töötada.
Õpetaja: Importi vaja.
Õpetaja: Importija, vaja. Vaadake, ma võtsin kogu selle styli bloki alt. Kõik need asjad ära, nii et see Leht enam tegelikult ei tea nendest stiiliasjadest ööd ega mütsi.
Õpetaja: Mis sest, et mul on siin öeldud? Vaata, et Purple ja mis, Sest et Isegi hüppab õigesse kohta. Kui ta kontrollib peale ja ta muutub hüperlingiks ja vastupidi ka,
Õpetaja: leian neid. Kuskil kohast on ju siis tegelikult on Niimoodi, mis puudutab nagu sellesse Htmili, siis tema ei ole absoluutselt teadlik. Ee, sellisest asjast nagu, ee, style punkt sees.
Õpetaja: Siis on meil vaja seda viidet kuskile panna. Ee, on vaja teha niukest linki. Nagu Siin on
Õpetaja: Link Relation Style Sheet, kus ta asub, seda on hästi natukene lihtsam teha, aga ta topib selle alati kuskile. Siia, Body alla. Kuhu Jumal teab? Kuhu iganes, Kui lihtsalt võtad selle Style Il kinni tulla kuidagi siia.
Õpetaja: Oh, tuli üldse kohta päge.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kus nüüd töötab.
Õpetaja: Nüüd töötab, Sest kui see Html loetakse, nüüd on see head, osa, mis on nagu nähtamatu osa versus titel, onju?
Õpetaja: Ei Ee, üheksakümnendate pank.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on. See on ju. See on heading kaine ainuke nähtav osa, Siis siin on kõik just metaandmed. Mida iganes Download, ida,
Õpetaja: Ee, siis. Põhimõtteliselt see link niiöelda siin ee teebki selle töö ära, et ütleb, et Ee, Niukene asi nagu Styleshit. Noh, see on Css asub sellises kohas. Source asset. Style Css Source assets Style Sss.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mul On midagi nüüd vaja. Mingi stiili sätetega. Midagi mudida. Just mingi värv. Üheks või Teiseks
Õpetaja: tuled siia. Kui mingid erilised värvid siis nagu kuvab Igal pool, kus värvikoode on, näiteks, Aga eelkõige on. Kogu staff on siin ja siin kusjuures on isegi okei koht, kus kommentaare ka panna,
Õpetaja: Inimesed võibolla panevad nagu sektsioonide kaupa mingisuguseid teatud stiili asju, et nad oleksid üksteistele.
Õpetaja: No mingi ongi mingi admini, mingid ee stiilisäted ja see on nagu suht Tavaline, mida ma olen näinud. Koht, kus on kommentaarid.
Õpetaja: Ee, pannakse. Kuidas see kommentaar käis? Siin oli kui vajutada Shift F Seitse siis ta teeb kommentaari rea. Noh, niimoodi. Nende vahel käib.
Õpetaja: Niukene markeering on et see, see ei ole stiil, see on lihtsalt, ee, Ee, meie lemmik Ago noh,
Õpetaja: no midagi taolist. Saate mõttest aru stiili. Eraldame esitlusest stiili saate.
Õpetaja: Htm veel annab sisu ja struktuuri
Õpetaja: Stiil Ee, Css annab stiili ja paigutuse.
Õpetaja: Väga mõnus.
Õpetaja: Ma mäletan, see oli nii ammu kui ma esimest korda nagu nägin Mingi Css failid asju. Mis asi. See mingi täielik jama
Õpetaja: ei ole. Jama.
Õpetaja: Jumal tänatud. Noh, see ongi. See tuleb ja ütleb, et. Kuule, see ago on ikkagi väga Nasti, et so nins.
Õpetaja: Asi on vajal, et see on palju ilusam, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Tuled siia, mõtled ära ja ongi kõik.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin Vita mida iganes tahad, Onju
Õpetaja: see siis ee. Paneme siis vahel, et
Õpetaja: see on niivõrd palju valmis olnud.
Õpetaja: Noh, onju, okei.
Õpetaja: Mm, Ega selle Statstiili kohta rohkem midagi väga polegi rääkida, Et ee. Oli siis algselt niimoodi et oli nende elementide sees. Siis ta oli siin kuskil üleval Ja nüüd on eraldi failis
Õpetaja: saab seda kasutada.
Õpetaja: Jah, mm,
Õpetaja: okei,
Õpetaja: ee. Jah,
Õpetaja: lähme. Või Noh, see see peab olema vaatamise koht ka. Vaata, Ma ütlen, et see saate tulla pärast järgi minu harule. Vaata, et õhtu on ka siin. Viimased kolmkümmend minutit
Õpetaja: ja niuksest kohast on kuulnud Nagu Goodsträck
Õpetaja: the Most Popular. Html. Ccs on The World. Äkki vä?
Õpetaja: Ee, kust see lause tuli?
Õpetaja: Mm, sinna ei taha kuidagi ära lõpetada. Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, me saame teha ühte tabelit.
Õpetaja: See Tabel
Õpetaja: siin on mingi näibistabel. Vaata, nagu. Et kuidas teha tabelit. Nüüd te näete, siin on Niukene asi nagu Glass Table.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis mõte on see, et näete, siin on nagu kenasti mingid reavahetused, jooned asjad. Noh, vaatame korra meie tabelit. Niiöelda vaatame, kuidas meie tabel välja näeb.
Õpetaja: Mis te sellest tabelist arvate?
Õpetaja: Versus, kui ta oleks võibolla näiteks Niuke just oleks kuidagi ilusam.
Õpetaja: No me vaatame ka veel, et värve saad muuta. Väga lihtsalt ainuke asi, mis pead muutma, on siis see, et see on nagu Näidiskood. Vaata, põhimõtteliselt siin peab mingeid muudatusi tegema,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, selline selline asi, mis siin praegu on näha, annab sellise
Õpetaja: tabeli. Proovime Jälgige, lähme tagasi üldse. Kuidas seda lisada? Saab?
Õpetaja: Kuidas on vanakooli vanakooli Ee värk on. Ee,
Õpetaja: see äkki piisab nendest kahest. Võibolla vist kuidagi. Niimoodi Näete See Siink
Õpetaja: Ma korra proovin. Ära Kõigepealt ärge kaasa tehke. Ee, ma tulen. Panen. Kui ma saan tööle, siis ee, siis on millestki rääkida, Sest ma ei ole seda installis sellisel kujul teinud.
Õpetaja: Like. Ee, never.
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et on ee, selline styleshit.
Õpetaja: Nii ja väikene tugi ka juurde. Mõned asjad on siin natuke interaktiivsed.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, siis ee. Nüüd on, niimoodi et kui see leht laetakse samamoodi, nagu ta importis, niiöelda ennem Lihtsalt siit selle faili. Nüüd lihtsalt tehakse seda kuskilt Väljastpoolt.
Õpetaja: Näed sträpp, minified, Csss.
Õpetaja: See on nagu siis kõik stiilid, mis tekitavad ee vastavaid tabeleid asju,
Õpetaja: et kui ma tulen, võtan selle Tabeli
Õpetaja: kogu selle koodikopi siin praegult. Lähen otsin selle meie tabeli ülesse Eesti Miraini ja asendan selle konkreetse näitega.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma nüüd tulen tagasi meie lehele,
Õpetaja: siis me näeme, et see sama näide on meil siin vastable,
Õpetaja: nagu ma Tahaks nüüd teha seda. Muudan selle pealkirja ära. Vaata, et siia panen eesnimi perekonnanimi. Selle kustutan ära ja nii edasi. Pole mõtet seda teha, Mis mõttes saate? Aru
Õpetaja: Pigem on nagu. See, et. Kas me saime mingi niukse välimuse?
Õpetaja: Ainukene asi, mis siin tegelikult üldse on, on see on klikin siia peale,
Õpetaja: siis ta põhimõtteliselt viib sinna kohta, et Ee. Minify teeb. Näed, sträpp
Õpetaja: Siin on Csss Sätted niimoodi, et kõik reavahetused Asjad on ära eemaldatud, et ta oleks failina minimaalne. See on selle faili nimi. Bootstrap. Minifide
Õpetaja: Selle minified ongi seda muuta. Igastah
Õpetaja: Ee, raamistikud Ja lahendused kasutavad ka, et lihtsalt sõna otseses mõttes teksti mõttes kokku hoida. Et võta ära kõik eba üle. Lihtsalt reavahetused, Spaced ja asjad, Et nagu nii kokku
Õpetaja: niivõrd palju kokku, kuni masin veel endiselt, saab sellest kõigest aru. Inimesele vist. Ee, Noh, kui ma ütleksin nagu siin, et Kuule, mine otsi ülesse siin mingisugune stiil. Ja mida see teeb, siis nagu mina ei tea, Good Luck, nagu
Õpetaja: ta vist on, ta vist on. Ta on tehniliselt võttes viiel Real. Kogu see asi.
Õpetaja: Oota, kus hakkab pihta vaatama. Tulen siia algusse tagasi. Näed, F, viis, paar kommentaari. Ja sisuliselt on kogu ülejäänud asi ühel. Real.
Õpetaja: Aga loomulikult on sellest nagu mingi normaalne variant ka olemas, mis ei ole minified, vaid on lihtsalt table.
Õpetaja: Ole väga tavaline. Tabel saab oma kujunduse siit. Table Color background, Color stripe color active hover.
Õpetaja: Head ja tead head. Jaa,
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd, kui me läheme selle lehele, siis me hakkame vaatama, et. Noh, see on see mingi base näide,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd öeldakse, et Kuule, Aga kui sa tahad, et see tabel oleks hoopis sinine,
Õpetaja: siis sa juba ütled. Table class Table primer, I
Õpetaja: et kui mina tulen siia Ja ütlen lihtsalt sidekriips raimari.
Õpetaja: Tulen lehele sees.
Õpetaja: Jah, Panen võibolla Refresh I.
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et siin peab olema juures kabel kaart, see Seda ei tohtinud ära võtta vaid juurde pidi panema.
Õpetaja: On sinine.
Õpetaja: Proovime. Danger on punane. Abel Tanger
Õpetaja: on punane.
Õpetaja: Oota, mis see veel on, Striped. Noh, keegi tahab niimoodi, et automaatselt ta teeb iga selle nagu erinevat värvi.
Õpetaja: Ee, see värk Table Dark Stripe
Õpetaja: Okei, all on õigemini Stripe Columns Strype.
Õpetaja: Kumba pidi Nüüd on? Vaata kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Ee, allpool Vist on näide kohe saan teada. No ma otsin näiteks midagi hovera peal. Näed, mustvalge. Käid hiirega pealt
Õpetaja: Võtaks? Pigem selle Table Table Hover, Tegelikult on ikkagi. Näed, Table. Table Dark Table Hover Näed, Kuidas on kombineeritav Et ta saaks üldse tabeli. Niiöelda Stiilid ja asjad. Aga Table Dark. Ja see, et ta saab ka Howerdada, kui ma hakkan pihta siit niimoodi, et ma panen lihtsalt kõigepealt table.
Õpetaja: Siis see tähendab seda, et meie lehel on ee, tavaline tark, aga ta ei ole see hover, iga.
Õpetaja: Võibolla tulen. Ütlen, et Kuule, lapime veel siin stiili juurde. Aa, mis oli tee peal? Hover vist oli, onju?
Õpetaja: Siis on nagu see, Et vähe sellest, et on tark, saab ka niimoodi. Nagu näha, mis reaal sa oled.
Õpetaja: Ja see oli lihtsalt nagu näide nagu praegult mingi, Aga on igasuguseid asju.
Õpetaja: No input palmot, label. Mulle meeldib näiteks label.
Õpetaja: Näiteks selline variant. Mulle õudsalt meeldib. Näete, see on Niukene, et see on input Box. Tal on label selle kasti sees. Aga kui sa klikid peale, siis ta läheb ülesse väikseks seest ära,
Õpetaja: kui mõinna kuidas Seda saab, palun väga. Siin on Html kood. Aga mis on Tähtis on see class.
Õpetaja: Need kõik viitavad.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellele
Õpetaja: Ee, See mõte on Nagu seda Boots Trap I sõna kasutatakse ka mujal. Ja selle idee on alati see kiirelt. Lihtsalt kuidagi saad asju hakata tegema, toimetama
Õpetaja: Tavaliselt Sellele vastupidi on see, et on Niukene standard mis nagu stiiliasjade puhul võib olla, niimoodi, et kui iga ma iga lehm maamuna kasutaks, on Vana hea nupp ja
Õpetaja: sekundari ja Primeri. Ja need samal värvil nagu Over Again. Aga see ei tähenda, et sa võiks võtta tegelikult seda endale põhjaks
Õpetaja: ja teha sinna Custom Css I peale
Õpetaja: important. Iga Lased sealt värvida juurest üle, kus tahad ja ja nii edasi edasi, on Teistsuguseid lähenemisi ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal on natuke teistsugune lähenemine. Seal on niimoodi, et sa saad samamoodi C sätetega nagu öelda, aga see käib natuke Teistmoodi, Umbes niimoodi, et tee nurgad kumeraks
Õpetaja: on mingi stiil.
Õpetaja: Lisa Mingi variand on mingi stiil. Ja nagu niimoodi sa kombineerides saad teha üsna Kiirelt saad teha nagu pigem nagu omanäolisema veebilehe. Aga sa ei pea ise hakkama. Cs I nagu kirjutama ja tegema.
Õpetaja: No ma arvan, et Nagu prestiižsemad ettevõtted, kellel nagu pappi on ja aega on. Nemad ikka teevad. Nagu pigem nagu üldse Custom It, nagu need ongi fondi arendajad Disainivad mingi disaini. Ja nad lihtsalt hakkavad siis seda nagu tegema, Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga, ee. Siis vahe on jällegi see, et sinna, läheb märkimisväärselt Rohkem raha ja aega teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtad mingi raamistiku? Vaatad kogu aeg sealt sealt leheküljelt. Mingisuguseid asju, mis sulle meeldib
Õpetaja: Kirjutad. Õige klassi nime, Pigem Copy Based. Võtad põhjad ja hakkad tegema et väga kiirelt saab teha disaini.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles mõttes et seal on kõik see funktsionaalsus olemas Tuleb käsi peale, Läheb Noolekeseks tulevad mingid varjundid asjad. Vaata, kasutaja saab, aru, et see selles mõttes on mõnus. Ja lihtne. Ee, Meie oma Õppeprojektis Kasutame ka Ja soovitan teil ka tegelikult pigem kasutada oma töödes Boots Trap I,
Õpetaja: kes tahab, võib muidugi panna. Kas ta on Csiga ka, aga see läheb. See läheb. Aa, ma arvan. Ajaraam on lihtsalt jõuab.
Õpetaja: Aga ma olen näinud muidugi üliägedaid disaine ka nagu tõsiselt.
Õpetaja: No Nüüd on muidugi Chat I ja igast muud asjad, kes aitavad ka teha. Nagu
Õpetaja: ma korra küsin selle me praegu panime seda stiili faili välise linna plaatsime päris elus. Pigem on pigem see enda koodibaasi alla laadida. Oled sõltumatu, kiirem.
Õpetaja: Mõlemad toimivad. Tehniliselt, onju aga Noh, jah, see Sama Ei, see, see. Ütleme see näide selles mõttes. Ega mul väga lihtne vajutada. Üks klikkida. Kogu see asi sealt niimoodi ka. Ja kui Me näiteks poes näeme. Siis seal ongi niimoodi, Et me ikka installime, et tõmmatakse sisse. Nad on
Õpetaja: lokaalselt serveris Olemas Just see sama põhjus Miks sa rääkisid ka,
Õpetaja: kui sa sõltu? Kui niipea, kui sa hakkad mängima kokku mingi väliste teenustega. See on väga suur riskifaktor juba. Aga Mis siis, kui see nende server paneb aa
Õpetaja: pildikotti? Vaata, siis on nagu Kuidas mul siis nagu asjad on onju eriti mingid funktsionaalsused ja Asjad on nagu eriti kriitiline. Vaata, Noh, välimused kannataks nagu, ära et järsku on mingisugune imelik välimus või mida iganes, ainult mingi Dexbox oleks, onju? Võibolla see kõik oleks asjad paigast ära ja nii edasi, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga midagi nagu oleks olemas. Aga iga kord, kui mingi välise teenusega ennast seod ee, siis see selles mõttes Niiöelda. Arhitektuuri mõttes on kalkuleeritud risk,
Õpetaja: et nagu ütleme, Aa kuskil nagu niukses viisakamas arendusettevõttes see ikka Väga kaalutakse läbi
Õpetaja: oma server on oma server. Kus asi on sul olemas? Noh, kui oma server kukub pikali, ma arvan, et siis ee, Need stiilijäed ja asjad on selline väiksem mure nagu pikali.
Õpetaja: No ma ei tea. Lhv pank. Näiteks paneb nagu pildi tasku Vaata, ja sa ei saa nagu tol hetkel. Nagu mõtlevad seda, et ma ei saa nagu internetipanka, et vaadata oma konto rääkida ei ole,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ja Ee, ja ma ütlen et meie, projektist me tõm Tõmbame. Need alla. Aa, mitte käsitsi,
Õpetaja: vaid Ee. Tegelikult Tehniliselt võttes polnud vist mul isegi vaja seda praegult alla tõmmata. Sest et kui me vaatame,
Õpetaja: näete seda rida siin dependentsis. See on tema skoop.
Õpetaja: Skoobi sees on puts drive See Tegelt on juba siin projektis olemas.
Õpetaja: Kuskil siin. Ee, nendes samades kogemata ongi lahti jäänud See kauss Seesama. Kuskil. Siin Ee, võiks olla. Midagi
Õpetaja: silma ei hakka.
Õpetaja: Midagi on Siin on ju avascript. Distribution Csss pole. Väga
Õpetaja: Noh, olemas. Tead, ta on meie serveris,
Õpetaja: aga ta ei Ole nagu selles mõttes Kitharis.
Õpetaja: Vaid see sama asi. See sama asi, Ee, mis on meil see? Ee, Tõmbame kokku tagasi, et see sama Frontend I Niiöelda defineerib, et kui Frontend server käivitub, Ta ehitab selle projekti täpi pealt samamoodi ülesse nagu meie arvutis, tõmbab alla, kõik, asjad Mis vaja,
Õpetaja: installib mida iganes ja siis käivitab.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee Davai Ootame natukene edasi. Veel mõned minutid on aega. Siis ma hakkan võibolla mõtlema, Mis ma teile jätan dudeerimiseks?
Õpetaja: Ee, et selline asi on nagu siis võimalik. Ja Seda me kindlasti kasutame.
Õpetaja: Jah, võibolla siis hästi natukene eelseisvat Staffi peakski hakkama vaatama, et me
Õpetaja: ma praegu siin rohkem midagi ei näita. Ma arvan, ma võin selle ära teha. Keegi tahab seda Work In progress, kolm.
Õpetaja: Ee. Saate seda pärast siis. Ee. Nii nagu õpetasime järgi tulla. Kes tahab Ega ma midagi väga ei teinud. Ja ma ütlen. Kogu see värk on prügikasti. Kaob
Õpetaja: me. Ei, me ei arenda üheksakümnendate ühist panka.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on siin ikka niisama harjutamine.
Õpetaja: Pigem mis Nüüd on, on see, et ee. Homme. Kui tuleme tagasi, siis läheme nagu veits põnevate teemade juurde ja see saab olema
Õpetaja: ja avascript ja Programmeerimine ehk siis interaktiivsus. See on nüüd siis see põhiline Rebo üldse millega me tegelikult kõige rohkem toimetame.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil hakkavad tulema mõningad mõisted Ja ma tahan, et mida varem te saate need selgeks, seda parem. Seal saab hästi palju paralleeli tuua. Tegelikult jaavaga ka
Õpetaja: on sarnased by The Way Ee Fun Fact ei. Küsimuste, viktoriine Küsimus
Õpetaja: mis. On ee ühist nendel kahel keelel java ja jaavas keelt mis, neid ühendab õlutib võiks niimoodi arvata, tootja.
Õpetaja: Neli esimest tähte. Mul midagi. Ee, selles mõttes, et, ee, kui Java Scripti tüübid tegid, siis Jaova oli juba olemas, Et, Ee, ärge unustage ära. Jaova on kombileeritav keel. Ta ei ole script. Ta ei jookse ülevalt alla ja len linnu lennu pealt ei tõlgendata asju, vaid ta on kompileeritav keel
Õpetaja: ja virtuaalne Masin Seda siis põhimõtteliselt Temaga toimetab kus iganes keskkonnas. Kas kui kohvikeetes kohvikeetus võib olla Täiesti vaba dialoog pole välistatud.
Õpetaja: Aa siis, Em.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt see keel tegelikult. Aa, visuaalselt on küllaltki sarnane. Jaavale
Õpetaja: ainult sellega, selle vahega, et ee Vaikimisi on tüübitundetu, aga Java on tüübikindel.
Õpetaja: Mida see tähendab? Seda, et me nendes mõlemas niiöelda keeles on võimalik luua muutujaid ja Mina tahan, et teie mõtlete muutujatest kui niisugustest sildikestes
Õpetaja: Sildikesed, Kuhu peale saab panna nime?
Õpetaja: Noh, meil siin oli ka juba paar nime
Õpetaja: Ee, mis jooksis läbi. Kõik on mingisugust heledat värvi.
Õpetaja: Okei, selle rohelise Aa, sul on must.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mina tahan, et te hakkasite mõtlema programmis ja kontseptsioonidele Ja Jätan teile veits materjali ka.
Õpetaja: Ja mina tahan, et ee, kui minu õppematerjalid seal selles vanas koolitused rääkisid muutujast kui ümbrikust mulle vanasti meeldis Ümbrik Täna mulle ümbrik ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Noh, tuleb modeenistust aega. Kes annab ikka niimoodi? Aa, ümbriku on ikka meeldiv. Siis kui on juubel ja Tuleb
Õpetaja: natuke raha tagasi.
Õpetaja: Noh, pool võib olla võib olla
Õpetaja: sildikene. Palju parem kui nimi. Ja meil on silt. Kuidas üldse silt, nagu tekib? Ee, ma ütlen kohe ette ära, et jaavas on nagu võtmesõnad lett
Õpetaja: ja võibolla varv ja lennuk Ee. See tähendab seda, et kui niipea Kuskil on sõna lett. Siis kandja tekib siin.
Õpetaja: Sildil on vaja nime.
Õpetaja: No, meil oli seal first name, last, name ja age. Ma kasutan,
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et ta on kõige tähtedega. Ta on kõige lihtsam siia kirjutada silt,
Õpetaja: sest siin taga tegelikult võib olla siis mingi number ja väärtus
Õpetaja: teisele poole praegu kirjutada Panen näiteks. Ee, ma nii suvel see vanusena, ma arvan Kaheksateist kvaliteeval.
Õpetaja: Näete, et see oleks nagu kaine nagu näide. Vaata, kui me kirjutaksime, tekib selline silt.
Õpetaja: Tal tekib nimi.
Õpetaja: Viimane osa on tal väärtus kaheksateist, mis on teisel poolel.
Õpetaja: Siit
Õpetaja: teeme natuke Veel ühe veel ja siis. Ee, vist. Ma pean midagi hakkama vaatama, et Mis, ma teile jätan.
Õpetaja: Mm, jah jaa, selge, David, mida paremat
Õpetaja: Nii kui ma kirjutaksin. Ee, no ütleme lihtsam. Ärme ärme veel mõtle.
Õpetaja: Ee, ärme hetkel veel mõtle. Jaavalt ma kirjutaksin lett ja ma panen siin.
Õpetaja: Kui mõjutatakse let ja students, siis see sõna Let tekitaks selle sildikese enda meil programmi.
Õpetaja: Aga ta ei ole nagu kuidagi kasutatav ega Miinitfull tal pole nime sellepärast, et kuidas sa saad sildi poole
Õpetaja: nagu viidata kui tal ei ole mingisugust nime
Õpetaja: ja nüüd on siis see Viimane asi, mis siin kõige tähtsam. Ja kui me hakkame vaikselt mõtlema juba objekt orienteeritud programmeerimist, Mida kiiremini te jõuate sellele ma ütlen, et Te mõtlete andmetest kui objektides seda lihtsam teil elu saab olema
Õpetaja: Nüüd kolmas komponent on objekt või väärtus? Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: kui see praegult on Lihtsalt let, student ja koodireal. Seal kõik lõpeb siis. Täpselt, Niuke, asi ongi olemas.
Õpetaja: Aga kui seal on Aa, let student ja näiteks, ee, võrdusmärgi taga on?
Õpetaja: Siis? Nüüd on meil kaks asja. Meil on tegelikult objekt.
Õpetaja: Ei tohi inimeste objektiks. Teha. Vaata, et see on nagu veits, Kõik on hästi, aga siis sellisel. Ma võin ise ka olla. Praegu, et. Ee. Siis on meil nagu kolm asja. Meil on see silt,
Õpetaja: Meil on selline nimi ja meil on midagi, mis on selle objekti taga,
Õpetaja: Mis on huvitav. Programmeerimises on see. Vaata, et see silt võib süsteemis olla. Aga see objekt siin taga võib tegelikult vahetuda.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui praegu keegi ütleks mulle Aa, kuskilt sealt klassiruumist. Kuule Hei, sina student Seal, Ma ei tea, Viska viis,
Õpetaja: Noh, siis. Praegusel juhul ta tegelikult viitaks, kui minule on ju,
Õpetaja: kui see silt oleks kellegi teise peal Ja tuleks samamoodi. Ütleks selle sama lause oleks Jaroslavi peal. Siis Tegelikult ta viitab Jaroslavi peale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd te peate aru saama, et me süsteemis Soovime tegelikult eelkõige suhelda andmetega?
Õpetaja: Meil on mingi hetk, kus andmed tekivad
Õpetaja: siis, kui meil tekivad mingeid andmeid, et me saaks edaspidi kuidagi viidata nendele andmetele, siis meil on vaja silti.
Õpetaja: Ilma sildita ei saa, et on mingi jutt. Mingisugusest Rain. Ist
Õpetaja: Tudent on tema asi. Aa, läheb Mingid tegevused asjad, onju? Kui nüüd olekski programmis tegevusel. Ee, Rain, Sul on aeg lõpetada teha mingi ettevalmistus teile ja siis minna nagu miitingule vaatama käsk. Vaata, et Rain, mine tee midagi, Onju,
Õpetaja: Et see Hiljed, selge on see, et Rail me praegu kutsume, student onju? See on Nagu minu, Nagu viide. Ee, selle abil on minu poole võimalik öelda mistahes hetkel
Õpetaja: seni kaua, kuni see silt on olemas ja siin mingi Objekt on taga ka. Võib juhtuda, et ühel hetkel programm saab läbi ja siis pole ei seda silti Ja pole objekti ka. No ma Loodan mina ikka alles olen ju? Aga. Aga ma mõtlen, nagu andmete mõttes. Nad kaovad.
Õpetaja: Mõelge muutujatest, kui siltidest.
Õpetaja: Mõelge sellele, et programmis ee on Siis nagu mingisugused erilised niiöelda ee, süntaksi võtted. Vaata, et kuidas tekib silt
Õpetaja: ja kuidas tekib objekt ja kuidas neid, kahte asja omavahel siduda ja alati aru saada sellest, et silt ei võrdu ise. Tingimata objektiga.
Õpetaja: Silt on seotud objektiga. Silt ja objekt on kaks erinevat. Asja Mina ei ole paberi lipakas. Mina ei ole lipakas,
Õpetaja: eks ole? Silt on paberilipakas.
Õpetaja: Vot
Õpetaja: niuksed. Väiksed mõtted. See kõik hakkab teil aja jooksul paika loksuma. Aga mida kiiremini te hakkate mõtlema ja visualiseerima seda kui muutujad, kui sildikesed ja ee, objektid,
Õpetaja: kui andmed
Õpetaja: ja kuidagi mõtlete seda Nagu võibolla, nagu päris elus. Siis teil ongi lihtsam sellest asjast aru saada, Mis asi on Objekti orienteeritud programmeerimine,
Õpetaja: sest et see on see, Millega me toimetame isegi avastada.
Õpetaja: Meil on objektid, Meil on sildid ja meil on tegevused nendega.
Õpetaja: Mm, tõmban siis ee, joone alla ja panen Siis lihtsalt teile praegult paar esimest teemat,
Õpetaja: mis just ka enda räägivad nendest asjadest vaikselt. Hakkame nendega tutvuma
Õpetaja: ja võibolla teeme siis niimoodi, et ma Siis homme lihtsalt niimoodi vabas vormis küsin. Vaata mõningaid küsimusi. Siis, Vaadake proovige. Vastata oma maalähedases lihtsas keeles. Kuidas aru saate
Õpetaja: Davai thats Kind a this. Mist selles mõttes, et ma nüüd toimetan? Valin teile mingit teemat. Soovib selline asi.
Õpetaja: Ja lepime siis kokku, et, noh, pooleni tiksuda. Vaata, Kui tegelikult tahate koju minna, siis minge.
Õpetaja: Saate võibolla puhata. Ka te on siin ee, ritsid. Ajad ees veel palju palju tööd
Õpetaja: Kuidas Ja Slaki? Panen, et ma hakkan praegult vaikselt Ee, midagi valima.
Õpetaja: Ee, panen selle tänase päeva. Kinni.
Õpetaja: Aa, üks asi veel. Mm, enne Kui ruttu tekitame uue kanali nimega,
Õpetaja: ei ole mõtet kanalit teha. See On hoopis ee, seal failis olemas.
Õpetaja: Zoomi Zoomi videod
Õpetaja: Ma panen pärast Jooksvalt selle lingi, et ma praegu sellel aega kulutan. Ma kulutan praegu aega, et ma valin mingid teemad.
Õpetaja: Ee, jälgige. Jälgige kogu aeg Channel I selles mõttes, et kui seal mingid sõnumid tuleb, siis tasuks ikkagi korra pilt peale visata.
Õpetaja: Ma vahel võibolla ka ei annagi teile kohe mingisuguseid asju jälgida. Ja siis lähen rongi peale. Siis mõtlen, et kurat oleks hea, kui nad homseks vaataksid. Seda või toda, et võibolla õhtul kodus korra Veel teha, Slack, Lahti
Õpetaja: vaadata. Kas ma midagi päeva lõpus viskasin? Ja need asjad ei ole nagu. Otseselt selles mõttes kuidagi siis ka kohustuslikud. Ee, vaid, Aa.
Õpetaja: Pigem nagu selles mõttes soovituslikud teie enda jaoks. Aga te ise tulite siia seda asja õppima. Ee, ma tean, et Te olete väsinud ja raske on näiteks õhtul midagi, nagu veel vaadata. Aga vahel on ülihea Õhtul viimase asjana teed mingi asja lahti, Loed ühe lehe ja vaatad. Vaata ja ei ole probleemi, et und ei tule.
Õpetaja: Nagu mõjub uinutavalt.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii.
Õpetaja: Ma panin Zoomi kinni. Või Väänad ei pannud.